bonjour à toutes et à tous nous sommes
en direct sur brut pour un live
exceptionnel avec le président de la
république
emmanuel macron qui va répondre à mes
questions mais aussi les vôtres depuis
quelques jours maintenant où vous a
sollicité vous la communauté de brutes
pour pouvoir construire cette interview
sur instagram facebook twitter vous avez
posé des milliers de questions et ces
milliers de questions et bien on en a
certes et ise beaucoup pour les poser au
président de la république jeudi on
parce que aujourd'hui vous avez
plusieurs personnes pour m'accompagner
yagmur cengiz tué reporters sur le
terrain pour brut depuis quelques mois
maintenant
bonjour à toi et thomas snégaroff
historien professeur d'histoire et qu'on
a la chance justement de voir très
régulièrement sur ces thématiques sur
brut bonjour bon jeu président jouera
tous les trois pour commencer je vais
vous raconter ce que j'ai vu et vécu
c'était il ya dix jours j'étais place de
la république à paris pour brut est ce
que j'ai vu pendant toute cette soirée
ce sont des migrants pourchassé et
molesté sortis de leurs tentes des
tentes qui vont même parfois être
confisquée par la police
c'était violent moi même j'ai été frappé
par un policier ça s'est poursuivi
jusqu'à une heure du matin
je les vois sur les trottoirs à
aubervilliers en périphérie la région
parisienne cent tentes sont couverture à
même le sol il faisait 5 degrés me suis
pris dans ce moment là de tels
comportements de la police en france en
est ce que c'est normal monsieur le
président non c'est jamais normal
d'avoir des comportements qui sont pas à
la hauteur des attentes qu'on a après il
faut essayer de comprendre dans quel
cadre
ils sont faits puis comment les corriger
et je voudrais pas accabler les
policiers qui sont intervenus ce soir là
et en général les policiers on y
reviendra je pense ce furent pour
évoquer toutes les questions parce
qu'ils sont eux mêmes placés dans des
situations qui sont extrêmement durs
pour lesquels ils n'ont pas toujours été
formé et en quelque sorte ils sont
confrontés à toutes les formes de
violence qui a dans la société
là on parle de la situation de des
migrants qui arrivent sur notre sur
notre territoire et donc vous avez
raison malgré mes engagements en début
de quinquennat parce que c'est un
engagement que j'ai pris comme président
qu'on puisse mieux hébergé accueillir on
n'y est pas encore pourquoi parce que la
pression migratoire continue et qu'on a
un vrai sujet de ce côté là
parce qu'il ya une exploitation de la
misère de la part de trafiquants et
services aussi il faut qu'on le voit
qu'on arrive à le dénoncer le et le
démonter et que lorsque ces femmes et
ces hommes qui fuient parfois des
conflits dans leur pays qu'ils
d'autrefois arrive par par ces réseaux
arrive chez nous la lenteur de nos
procédures fait qu'ils peuvent en effet
pendant des semaines des mois se
retrouver dans des situations là et donc
quand il ya des interventions de ce type
il faut tout de suite qu'on ait une
solution pour les loger et donc est ce
qu'il fallait
est ce qu'il fallait à la place de la
république faire enlever les tentes
oui parce que ça n'est pas normal qu'ils
aient des tentes dans les rues en france
c'est ce que derrière il y aussi ces
images de violence de façon non des
attelages et bien sûr je vais venir tous
deux signés sur les violences mais
est-ce qu'il fallait enlever les tentes
oui parce que on ne peut pas accepter
que ces femmes et ces hommes dorment
dans la rue peut pas l'accepter pour on
peut pas l'accepter non plus pour les
riverains est ce que on ne doit le faire
tant qu'on n'a pas de solution
d'hébergement d'urgence de relogement
non et donc on doit le faire à chaque
fois avec cette solution
derrière c'est le seul moyen de régler à
très court terme la solution la
situation par don humanitaire que ces
femmes et ces hommes connaissent sur
notre sol après le vrai sujet la racine
du problème que nous avons aujourd'hui
réglé c'est que moi je défendrai
jusqu'au bout le droit d'asile le droit
d'asile c'est protéger les combattants
de la liberté
d'où qu'ils viennent mais aujourd'hui la
question de raser mais ces images au
site violence un nom mais je vais aussi
les faits même les images et les faits
c'est fait après j'explique ça qu'après
on va revenir sur des violences
quelle qu'en soit la forme et donc ça le
droit d'asile on le protègera toujours
mais aujourd'hui le droit d'asile
il est détourné par des réseaux des
trafiquants et vous avez beaucoup de
gens qui arrivent qui n'auront jamais
droit à l'asile parce qu'ils ne viennent
pas de l'endroit où ils sont menacés où
il ya un conflit politique
mais en quelques heures un quelque sorte
c'est un contournement du droit d'asile
pour aider à des filières d'immigration
illégale ça on doit le stopper
sinon on sera toujours débordé il ya
rien qui justifie les violences et donc
quand la police intervient elle doit
toujours le faire dans un cadre
déontologique exemplaires et donc c'est
pour ça que c'est ça n'a pas été le cas
ce soir ce qui a été début je mangeais
pas être juge
il ya une procédure qui a été lancé ce
que je note c'est que dès le lendemain
il ya une inspection qui a été demandée
par le préfet de police ministre
que l a permis d'identifier des fautes
très clairement et qu'il y aura donc des
sanctions et que les auditions
continuent donc il faut qu' à chaque
fois des sanctions et je peux pas
laisser dire que quand la police
intervient et qu'il ya des images comme
ça ou des fautes qui sont faites
elles sont laissées lettre morte il ya à
chaque fois 10 ans 4 qui il faut aller
au bout de ses enquêtes ensuite pour
aller jusqu'à la sanction est justement
cette soirée dont je vous ai parlé ça a
été le début d'une série de révélations
de violence policière ces images que
vous avez aussi monsieur le président
celle de michel est clair ce producteur
de musique qui pendant près de quinze
minutes va être frappé par plusieurs
policiers une scène où vous avez exprimé
votre honte monsieur le président mais
qu'est ce qui vous a fait honte
précisément dans ces images basque il
nous a fait honte à tous c'est que les
policiers ne soient pas exemplaire et je
pense que tous les policiers de france
les gendarmes tous ceux dé ceux qui sont
dans les forces de sécurité ont ressenti
la même chose donc ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est pourquoi ils en sont
arrivés là pourquoi ils ont ils se sont
comportés de cette manière rien qu il
excuse et qu'ils justifient la justice
s'en est saisi et il m'appartient pas
moi d'aller plus loin sur ce sujet ce
qui m'a fait honte sont les faits au
delà des images
vous savez il ya beaucoup de pense de
jeunes ou moins jeunes policiers qui
appartiennent à la communauté de brutes
qui vous suivent et ils sont dans la
société
et s'ils s'engagent ils s'engagent pour
servir pour protéger aucun ne s'engage
pour prendre des coups pour en donner et
donc quand il ya des policiers et des
policières ou des gendarmes ou quel que
soit d'ailleurs celles et ceux qui
servent la république qui ont des
comportements qui sont pas à la hauteur
de cet engagement
c'est encore plus grave parce qu'il faut
tout de suite y répondre il faut tout de
suite que ça puisse être identifié
sanctionnés soit de manière
disciplinaire c'est à dire par le
ministère de l'intérieur lui même soit
par la justice mais ensuite ce qui est
important parce que je voudrais qu'on
soit juste moi j'ai été très choqué par
ces images et parce qu'il a subi
parce que c'est inacceptable et j'ai vu
comme vous samedi des images aussi
graves parfois plus ou une femme
commissaire de police s'est fait rouer
de coups mais par des manifestants mais
je vais sur on n'est pas justin ans si
on regarde pas la société dans son
ensemble on n'est pas juste ce qui s'est
déroulé place de la bastille elle a été
attaquée par des fous a aussi des gens
en sauvage est complètement
ce que ce terme monsieur le président
mais mettez un signe égal entre des
violences exercées par un via la
violence dans la société par un citoyen
sur un policier
alors j'attends d'un policier
l'exemplarité et donc il ya je dirais
zéro tolérance des deux côtés mais ce
qui est très important c'est qu'on n'est
pas qu'un regard sur une part de la
violence
c'est ça ce que je veux dire parce que
sinon vous allez vous ne sortirait
jamais d'une espèce de circularité ou en
quelque sorte je le dis entre guillemets
il ya le citoyen victime et le policier
violent il ya de la violence dans notre
suspens en termes de violon il ya de la
violence dans notre société il y à des
policiers violents il en a et donc là
dessus il faut prévenir formé alors et
surtout sanctionnez
mais si on est juste alors il ya des
policiers le lendemain ils sont amenés
des violences policières monsieur le
président est ce que ce qui s'est passé
dans ce studio 21 novembre ce sont des
violences policières ça s'appelle
comment ça c'est ce qui a été filmé qui
a vu les images oui ça s'appelle comme
ça ce terme là jusque non parce que je
vais vous dire pourquoi ce terme là
d'abord il est politisée les black
blocks une partie de l'extrême gauche
qui veut la dissolution de l'état a
installé l'idée au jeu installé l'idée
en quelque sorte qu'il y à une violence
consubstantielle à la police comme
d'autres disent il ya un racisme
consubstantielle à la police ça c'est
non je suis contre ça d'abord parce que
c'est pas vrai mais non c'est pas vrai
c'est faux c'est une manipulation et ça
c'est quelque chose dont le but est
d'affaiblir une institution républicaine
les policiers les policières les
gendarmes il s'engage pour servir ils
sont pas dans un camp il protège l'ordre
républicain
c'est à dire ce qu'ils font ils le font
au nom de la loi qui a été votée par
celles et ceux qui nous représentent
ils sont pas dans un camp ils sont pas
dans la vengeance et par un contre
l'autre ils défendent un ordre
tant et si bien que quand vous êtes
cambriolé sans vous vous êtes agressé
cet aveu vous faites appel par la
dotation
il ya quelque chose que je comprends pas
mais attendez y danser quand le terme de
violences policières
il ya la violence des policiers vous
l'avez utile pendant les campagnes
pourquoi parce que parce que les choses
sont en train de se transformer très
fortement que maintenant c'est devenu un
slogan je jouerai vous citez vous avez
je sais c'est que je pense 2010 16/0
tolérer les yeux non quand il y à des
violences policières violence policière
sur le terrain on doit donner tout
éclaircissement à ces violences c'est ce
terme de violences policières que vous
avez mais il m'avouera même à le redire
je veux simplement dit le pourquoi vous
de jeu le déconstruit en disant il ya
une violence des policiers il y à des
violences deux policiers c'est tout à
fait vrai donc ne vous n'êtes pas des
violences vous d'un petit c'est un
énorme à faire ce qui est en train de se
battre et ce depuis maintenant trois ans
pour clarifier juste arrivé en 2010
est il y avait donc selon le maquereau
candidats des violences policières
depuis il ya des violences des policiers
c'est sympa du tout il ya la même chose
le même phénomène qu'on constate qu'on
continue de voir est ce que c'est un
tabou de dire le terme sinon je peux
vous dire il ya des violences policières
si ça vous fait plaisir que je le dise
on va pas jouer a dit oui ni non ça je
veux dire c'est pas ça le but pour
certains ça pèse c'était partie de la
population parce que nous on le voit on
lit les commentaires
on a vu ces images à moi c'est
l'allégorie jeudi que les faits quand on
a vu ces faits également michel c'est
clair et d'autres voix s'élèvent un
sport tu y as pas et c'est pas ça c'est
que je me suis aperçu que pour beaucoup
de gens qui ont un projet politique et
qui veulent simplement affaiblir
décrédibiliser la police est devenue un
slogan ça ne l'était pas au moment où
j'ai dit ça et donc les choses se sont
durcies ces dernières années une
manifestation doit travailler en 2016
vous êtes gentils de rappeler que ça va
commencer depuis que président mais
c'était mal gré mais je dis que là ça
fait structure et donc je moi j'ai aucun
problème si on est dans une discussion
comme ça pour dire qu'il ya des
violences policières
mais je n'aime pas donner crédit à un
concept il ya de la violence dans la
société
il y à du racisme dans la société
aujourd'hui en france c'est un fait
et donc comme on a une police qui est à
l'image de la société
et bien il y a des manques de la police
qui ont des comportements violents qu'il
faut pouvoir traquer et sanctionner
il ya des ventes de la police qui ont
les attitudes racistes qui sont pas
acceptables mais est ce que pour autant
et la police après est-ce que est ce que
pour autant c'est l'institution qui
laissait l'ensemble des policiers non
parce que pas rentrer dans les
proportions mais pensez aux 95 % de
policiers qui sont engagés quitterait
qui ont pris beaucoup de coups qu'ils
ont eux mêmes été blessés qui sont
soumis à des agressions dont on doit
aussi parler eux
si vous leur dites il ya des violences
policières c'est mon principal problème
ils deviennent fous ils ont le sentiment
d'une injustice impossible parce qu'ils
servent les lois républicaines parce
qu'ils sont là pour vous protéger
donc voyez ce fait ce distinguo entre
des individus et on doit corriger ça
être intraitable et entre une
institution et un ensemble mais vous
parler de ce que je vois sur le terrain
moi pour brut je vais souvent dans les
quartiers dans les quartiers populaires
et quand je rencontre des personnes
quand on me parle de la police on me dit
souvent on a peur de la police
on a peur
de la part des contrôles on a peur de se
faire interpeller parfois on se fait
interpeller on a des contrôles deux à
trois fois dans la même journée
qu'est ce que vous dites à ces jeunes
alors il ya plusieurs choses d'abord je
le disais on a de la société devenue
plus violente
ça c'est vrai et donc la police est
embarqué dans ce cycle de violence et on
ne peut s'en sortir que si on arrive
d'abord à traiter la racine pourquoi ya
de la violence souvent dans les
quartiers à cause du trafic des stups
qui ont créé une économie avec des gens
très violents qui sont prêts à tout pour
préserver cette économie et donc ça
c'est le plan ce tube qu'on a lancé pour
essayer d'aller à la racine et de calmer
les choses parce qu'on aura à traiter le
mal ensuite on a de la violence urbaine
qui s'est installée qui ne date pas
d'hier
la buzine l'a rappelé à juste titre mais
qui c'est je dirais accrue tant qu'on
n'aura pas traiter ensemble ce sujet et
moi j'ai besoin de tout le monde pour le
faire c'est pas la police seule il faut
qu'on améliore notre capacité aussi je
dirais à dénoncer avertir prévenir mais
on a aujourd'hui quand on regarde les
manifestations à paris 300 400 personnes
qui sont là pour qu'une manifestation
tourne mal et ça c'est un style osé
pourquoi on en est là aujourd'hui parce
que je pense que on a vu partout en
europe cette violence monte il ya
quelques années on a eu le g20 qui était
hambourg avec une violence terrible et
on a ce phénomène qui depuis le début
des années 2000 et là il ya une violence
d'extrême droite très forte qui a
maintenant une violence aussi d'extrême
gauche dan ar anti flics je reprends
leurs thèmes et donc c'est aussi pour ça
que je suis très vigilant quand on parle
de violences policières je veux pas leur
donner des arguments et qui en quelque
sorte fait en sorte que la pression
retombe jamais et donc cette il ya la
violence urbaine qui est liée au trafic
de drogue
il ya la violence des manifs qui est lié
à ces gens qui viennent en chèques en
quelque sorte à chaque fois volé la
manifestation à celles et ceux qui sont
là bas mais librement il ya moody's et
autres choses à lui disais oh oui parce
qu'elle parlait aussi des contrôles
contre le pas de trop au faciès et ça
n'a rien à voir cela n'a rien à voir
mais j'explique ça c'est une question
qui ont conduit son directeur de la
police c'est la violence et donc la
violence jeudi le seul moyen de faire
c'est d'abord que tous ensemble on
essaie d'isoler d'où vient la violence
quel est l'élément déclencheur quand une
manif se passe bien c'est pas vrai dire
qu'un policier qui va taper quand une
manif commence à s'embraser
c'est là où il peut y avoir une escalade
avec aussi nos forces de police qui je
veux le dire ont été soumises à trois
années avec énormément de manifestations
de manifestations violentes et ont tenu
aussi pour une écrasante majorité
déontologie une capacité à ce qu'il y
ait le moins de débordements possibles
qui étaient là donc je veux rendre les
images pendant le vendée gilet jaune on
a vu parfois des policiers enfin même
parfois de nombreuses fois des policiers
utilisés mais je n'avais pas une police
à l'américaine où vous avez à déplorer
sur ces manifestations développeurs de
violences policières où il ya eu et je
veux dire je pense à le rappeler parce
que eux-mêmes et qu'ils vont vers des
manifestants qui vont parfois les
frapper ou autre c'est déjà arrivé à ce
que j'avais je vous avez raison même
sens mais je voudrais qu'on ait la même
vigilance pour traquer la violence qui a
dans les manifs nation et ça on est pas
soyons honnêtes entre nous même on n'est
pas équitable même avec l'institution
policière
et donc nous devons aussi dire comment
on fait pour que les quelques milliers
france entière qui sont là pour courir
toutes les manifs pour qu'il y ait de la
violence qui se déclenche pour que tout
devienne fou comment on fait pour le
stopper donc ça moi j'ai besoin de vous
pour qu'aussi mon sortent des manifs ces
gens là qui sont impossibles et ensuite
comment on empêche ce que vous dites
1 la formation on l'avait longtemps
négligé on lui remet le paquet on a
besoin d'être formés pour pas pour pas
que tout ça s'embrase c'est très
important de l'encadrement
le ministre l'a redit ça c'est vrai il
ya une police qui a eu à subir des
baisses de personnel l'encadrement
intermédiaire mais de terrain quand il
n'est pas forcément suffisamment présent
voilà on s'échauffe on s'embrasse et on
commet des choses qui sont intolérables
et ces violences troisième chose c'est
de mettre de la transparence pour ça moi
je veux qu'on sorte de tout ça
collectivement par le haut je vous dis
et des mois en dénonçant aussi ceux qui
sont violents faut continuer à dénoncer
les policiers qui sont violents pour
qu'on ait des actions faut continuer
aussi à dénoncer les gens qui sont
violents c'est la généralisation de la
caméra de la caméra pour les policiers
qui sont en intervention comme pour les
brigades est donc là on n'arrive pas à
piéton oui c'est essentiellement alors
on a dû repasser tous les marchés parce
que pour tout vous dire ma dit au début
on a des caméras ça va vous verrez ça va
se déployer
et puis les caméras sont déployés les
policiers ne les utilisez pas pourquoi
parce qu'on avait un produit qui n'était
pas de qualité il y avait une autonomie
de 3 heures on a repassé un appel un
appel d'offres à partir de juin on les
aura donc à partir de juin je compte
déploie le plus vite possible c'est la
meilleure protection et que ça puisse
être utilisé d'ailleurs par la justice
parce que moi je pense que quand
quelqu'un déclenché les hostilités si je
puis dire ou attaque et qu'il est filmé
il s'emporte appareils quand un policier
sait qu'il est en permanence en train de
filmer ses actions il se comporte
apparaît
donc ça la transparence et
d'accessibilité ces images c'est aussi
un point et l'accessibilité de ces
images mais là pour le coup total la
tonne en particulier à la justice
évidemment et et à la hiérarchie pour
pouvoir aller où et donc ça on a besoin
de contenir on a besoin aussi de former
sur le terrain et d'avoir sans doute
davantage et ça c'est vrai qu'on l'a
perdu ces dernières années deux
médiateurs d'ailleurs pour pas que ça se
le tour de la police de proximité ça
monte
la police de sécurité du quotidien la
remise mais là on parle de situation de
maintien de l'ordre celles que vous
évoquez celle que vous filmez c'est pas
la police de sécurité c'est de mettre
des gens qui sont formés qualifié pour
le faire avec des gens qui vont aider à
la désescalade quand les choses en
matière qui vont parler qui sont un
entre deux et ça c'est vrai que là
dessus on doit s'améliorer
donc ça c'est le si je puis dire c'est
l'organisation après vous avez soulevé
un problème qui est très important celui
des discriminations et ce problème on
l'a pas réglé malgré mes engagements je
suis obligé de le constater
parce qu'on a quand j'écoute les jeunes
ou moins jeunes
en tout cas toutes celles et ceux qui
ont une bonne raison d'être discriminés
parce qu'ils sont maghrébine maghrébins
ou d'origine maghrébine parce qu'ils
sont noirs parce que voilà leur couleur
de peau leur allure le quartier fait que
tout est prédisposé ils se sentent
discriminés et donc ça commence comme ça
et en effet à ce moment là la haine de
la police
comment cela et les quelques chiffres
dont on dispose ils disent il dit ça
mais pourquoi une telle fracture
aujourd'hui il ya une fracture parce
qu'il ya une défiance qui s'est installé
dans les quartiers les plus difficiles
entre la population et la police
et est ce qu'on est en train de se dire
sur la violence on peut le dire sur les
contrôles c'est que la défiance elle se
nourrit elle même elle se nourrit elle
même c'est à dire je leur dis moi un
policier il s'engage pas pour faire pour
faire ça son métier comme ça comme
aujourd'hui on lui impose en france je
veux qu'on n'oublie pas parce que je
veux pas qu'on soit injuste avec les
policières et les policiers ou avec les
gendarmes
mais quand il est placé dans un tel
niveau de stress de pression lui même de
violence de la société
il y avait un moment des comportements
qui se conditionnent de la défiance qui
se créent et la réaction elle va nourrir
elle même cette propre défiance et donc
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on a une
couleur de peau qui n'est pas blanche on
est beaucoup plus contrôler beaucoup
plus et encore plus quand on est
d'ailleurs souvent un garçon
parce que on est identifié comme étant
un facteur de risque de problème est que
c'est insoutenable et donc la seule le
seul moyen de faire ça parce qu'on a
tout dit tout essayer et moi même je
suis fatigué de l'avoir dit et de là où
je suis honnêtement je suis pas
tellement crédible si je vous disais ça
sans bouger donc le seul moyen de bouger
c'est de faire ce qu'on a su faire sur
d'autres violences ou d'autres sujets
sensibles
c'est de mettre en place une plate forme
commune pour que les gens puissent
dénoncer de manière très simple unique
et national et donc ce qu'on va mettre
en place à partir de janvier prochain
ces deux choses d'abord un grand sondage
comme l'ont fait les britanniques
sos racisme avait proposé d'ailleurs il
ya quelques mois et on a trop tardé à le
faire il avait raison un grand sondage à
partir de janvier sur une plateforme
internet où les gens pourront aller dire
en quoi ils sont discriminés et où il ya
le contrôle au faciès
il ya le logement il ya l'emploi il ya
des quotidiens de la vie la deuxième
chose sur les contrôles c'est qu'on va
mettre en place une plateforme nationale
avec un numéro d'appel la possibilité de
signaler et ce sera géré par l'état le
défenseur des droits et des associations
compétentes en la matière en particulier
la licra est donc cette ça lui va en
découdre c'est une plate forme de
signalement c'est parce que la seule
mais le seul moyen de faire c'est ce
qu'on voulait un moment comme on signale
ckoi part en hausse est de 7 ce sera un
numéro est un site internet où on pourra
en effet un signal et deux si on a
besoin d'être écoutés et coûté 3 aussi
tout de suite ce qui est important parce
que ça doit pas rester lettre morte
la possibilité d'avoir un suivi si on
veut porter plainte ensuite dans le même
temps on va lancer à partir de là une
procédure de formation des policiers et
des gendarmes pour pouvoir prendre sa
déposition et répondre à ces problèmes
on l'a qualifié dans la loi font pas
changer la loi là dessus il faut juste
l'appliquer comme il se doit parce que
qu'on soit discriminée selon sa couleur
de peau selon son origine
qu'on soit attaquée parce qu'on a une
religion goats est déjà interdite par la
loi donc il faut simplement le faire
appliquer donc on va former des
policiers des gendarmes pour ce faire et
on va aussi former des juges pour avoir
des cellules de réponse beaucoup plus
rapide avec des juges qui sont
compétents en la matière on va
s'inspirer de quoi de ce qu'on a su
développer sur les violences faites aux
femmes de manière très concrète ou
pendant très longtemps parlé du problème
on n'a pas su régler et en mettant en
place cette plateforme on a mis les
associations défenseur des droits
policier jean
d'armes magistrat on a su commencé à le
régler et donc ça on va mettre en place
à partir du début d'année prochaine
ça va prendre du temps comme tous les
grands changements sociaux mais moi je
suis convaincu que si on fait ça si on
met la caméra piétons y compris pour les
contrôler si on lance des opérations
aussi on propose que sur les contrôles
de rue y aider des citoyens témoins
qu'ils soient là membres d'associations
ou autre on peut recréer la confiance
mais vous pas justement de la confiance
rétablir la confiance en la police y est
aussi la question des sanctions
on parle souvent de l'igpn certains
pointent du doigt un manque
d'indépendance c'est l'egypte nc la
police des polices quelque part souvent
cette seconde d'indépendance il est
pointé du doigt qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez répondre à ça aujourd'hui ce
qu'on n'a pas une façon de pouvoir avoir
un climat peut-être plus sereins
confiants envers les gens que je pense
qu'il faut d'abord moi je dans tous les
corps dans tous les ministères vous avez
des gens qui inspectent et qui vérifie
et ça doit être utilisé pour justement
procéder à des sanctions disciplinaires
ou au pouvoir promouvoir les gens quand
ils quand ils sont bons ça sert à ça
donc qui est un corps d'inspection qui
soit très indépendant et qui soit auprès
du directeur général de la police et du
ministre je pense est une bonne chose si
on le sort totalement comme j'entends
certains ont fait de ce qu'on peut
donner des évolutions aujourd'hui ce
qu'on fait alors je pense que il faut
encore lui donner plus de force à l'eau
non stratégiques comme ça c'est
d'ailleurs fait par le passé c'est à
dire une vraie indépendance sur les
sanctions les choses qui sont faites je
pense qu'il ya deuxième chose c'est
qu'il faut plus de transparence sur le
suivi parce que les images sont là les
débats sont publics
vous les rangs des publics dans la
discussion donc encore une fois je
moi j'ai pas comme comme dirait l'un de
mes anciens compétiteurs j'ai pas de
pudeur de gazelle sur le sujet je quand
je parle de vue je suis prêt à parler de
violences policières je préfère dire
qu'il ya des avions chez les policiers
pour les raisons que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure mais il faut le traiter
donc si on veut être efficace il faut
que au delà des faits quand ils émotions
on puisse dire dans la durée voilà ce
qui a été fait pour y répondre
donc ce qui est très important c'est
qu'ils ont ensuite une communication des
sanctions qui sont pris sur cette valve
ensuite je pense qu'il faut beaucoup
plus surtout fréquemment et s'administre
s'en est saisie mise de l'intérieur a
commencé à le faire saisir la commission
des sanctions
et puis après quand c'est grave mais
j'attire votre attention et la justice
qui se saisit l'expérience
malheureusement qu'on a vécu avec ce
qu'a eu à subir
le producteur michel z norred des coups
qu'il a eue qu'il a eu à subir et de
l'émotion que ça a créé plus que
légitime
il ya une réponse de la justice elle a
même commencé cette réponse de la
justice avant que l'outsider ne diffuse
les images elles sont diffusées par
l'obs haider le jeudi la justice en est
saisi dès le mardi
donc ce serait faux de dire que les
institutions républicaines sont passives
et attendre les mois et il ya un rapport
qui rend donc si on résume et le week
end il ya la justice qui est saisie le
mardi et je veux par rapport à votre
question bien sûr l'igpn serbie le
procureur a la possibilité de saisir
l'igpn ce qu'il fait dès le mardi
et quand l'igpn l'inspection générale de
la police nationale est saisie par le
procureur elle intervient sous son
autorité elle ne partage plus d
informations avec les collègues et elle
ne remonte pas les informations aux
ministres elle les donne directement au
procureur donc dans un cadre d'
indépendance parce que c'est un cadre
judiciaire monsieur le président il ya
des sanctions contre les policiers vous
ne m'en parlait et puis il y a la
responsabilité de la hiérarchie
policière
oui je vais vous citer mais j'en ai
parlé dans la même je pense la même
interview que c'est un petit peu plus
tard et c'est moi vous êtes mais
récemment né le 5 mai 2017
deux jours avant votre élection avant le
second tour voilà ce que vous dites à ce
moment là c'est vous qui parlez ce n'est
pas possible
quand il y a eu une violence policière
qu'il n'y aucune sanction dans la
hiérarchie policière
il y à un commissaire de police il y a
un directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique
il y à un préfet il y a un ministre est
vrai ce que vous dites
donc moi je crois en une république de
la responsabilité
je crois qu'on a vu et vous l'avez vous
même dire que depuis quelques semaines
de manière évidente il ya un problème
et pourtant ni le préfet de police
didier lallement
ni le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin n'ont été remis en cause par
vous et d'abord à chaque fois qu'un
problème moi j'interroge le ministre et
le préfet qui est concerné ensuite quand
il ya un problème faut essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe et la
réaction elle doit être juste et
proportionnée
vous parliez de la république ait eu
immédiatement une inspection qui a été
demandé de ce soir même
des sanctions sont en train de préparer
et il y en aura sur la hiérarchie
policière haut niveau
c'est pas moi qui la prends c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur donc carrière
j'avais policière par exemple le préfet
de police ça peut être la question si
c'est une erreur qui a été fait sur ce
qui est déclenché par le préfet de
police
ces deux préfets de police qu'à ce
moment-là définit comme responsable et
ses comptables il est c'est une je vais
y revenir parce que j'ai su le faire par
le passé
bien évidemment si si c'est une erreur
d'exécution c'est la personne
encadrement qui est responsable
et là c'est la vue sur certaines scènes
il ya manifestement l'encadrement de
terrain est ce que les choix qui sont
ceux du préfet de police ou du ministre
sont en cause sur ces deux situations la
réponse telle que les informations sont
remontées sur lui sur le d'un point de
vue administratif et non après sur le
deuxième sujet qui sont violence qu'a
subie sur le premier michel ni mr
interne mystérieux l'inter ne donne
l'ordre d'évacuer la place de la
république
lille préfet de police on rappelle que
sur cette place de la république et des
unités de maintien lors qu'ils n'étaient
pas formés jour là il ya des bac de nuit
notamment l'aide n'est pas du tout la
même vision et cette vision elle est
prise par la hiérarchie est la décision
d'arrêter totalement prise par le préfet
de police
en accord avec le cabinet de ministres
la question est est ce que cette
décision était illégitime
la réponse est non je voulais dit tout à
l'heure c'était bonne décision de
justement permettre l'évacuation de la
place de la république je vous ai dit
moi je souhaitais que j'ai demandé c'est
qu'à chaque fois qu'on évacue et on
trouve une place justement d'hébergement
c'est là où j'ai un problème
est ce que dans le cas ce soir là mais
c'est pas un problème ça dépend des
situations il ya des têtes d'évacuation
ont fait don à ce moment là on ne parle
pas ou on a des solutions d'hébergement
il n'est 60 rappelle qu'au moment où on
se parle ou au moment où on se parle on
a deux milliards d'euros par an qui sont
dépensés sur l'hébergement d'urgence ce
qui est ce qui est un chiffre qui n'a
jamais tête
donc je pourrai pas laisser dire que le
gouvernement ne fait rien mais donc ça
c'est pas un problème opérationnel après
celles et ceux qui ont exécuté mais
c'est je ne vais pas me substituer au
ministre de l'intérieur a nié ces
équipes
ils auront des décisions à prendre je
vous aider par contre je donne un autre
exemple quand il ya eu le problème de l'
attaque terroriste à marseille et qui a
eu une erreur qui a été fait ou on a
libéré personne qui a produit cette
attaque qui a tué 2 charlie à la gare
saint-charles en cra il y a eu des
fautes quand on a remonté la chaîne
cfoot remonter jusqu'à la proximité très
proche d'un préfet qui était aussi un
préfet de région est un très grand
serviteur de l'état
très grand serviteur de l'état j'ai pris
la décision à ce moment là de le limoger
parce que je considérais que c'était une
décision qui a été prise dans sa
proximité et qui ne remettait pas en
cause les qualités personnelles de ce
préfet de région mais qui justifier le
fait qu'il soit justement considérés
comme responsables mais simplement je
sais très bien les obsessions qui lie à
ce préfet de police mais c'est pas deux
semaines et non mais parce que après on
focalise le débat sur quelques personnes
qui sont plus médiatiques mais moi je
pense mais c'est parce qu'elles ont
violé ticks et des personnes qui sont en
charge en mai bien non la hiérarchie
mais à chaque fois il faut voir est-ce
que l'erreur est les politiques quand il
y en a une
est ce qu'elle est ensuite
d'opportunités de décisions wasquehal et
d'exécution et quand je des décisions
que je prends depuis plus de trois ans
sont encore fumant en conformité totale
avec ce que vous avez lu tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce que non mais je n'avais pas
considéré à chaque fois qu'il ya un
problème sur le terrain bien ce que
c'est les hiérarchies la plus haute qui
responsables sinon on fait la valse
chaque semaine dans le cas de michel z
pour l'instant selon vos informations il
n'y a aucun manquement de la hiérarchie
policière
je n'avais absolument pas me prononcer
sur une affaire qui est dans les mains
de la justice et les mots employés par
le ministre de l'intérieur quand il dit
par exemple les policiers qui ont
agressé michel z ont déconné qu'est ce
que dit le président de la république
jeudi qu'ils ont été d'une d'une
violence est inadmissible et je pense
que tous les policiers et policières ont
ressenti je moi je veux comprendre
pourquoi et pourquoi ce comportement
était possible parce que j'ai besoin de
comprendre je pense que la sanction doit
être implacable et je pense que il est
essentiel aussi qu'elle soit implacable
pour ne pas salir le reste les pôles
voilà de l'institution et des policières
et des policiers
je le redis mai mais ce qui est
important dans les débats parce que vous
allez me dire que je me répète mais
j'espère avoir répondu sur chacun des
points c'est qu'on soit juste c'est que
moi je regarde aussi les milliers de
policiers deux policières qui ont subi
des violences depuis trois ans qui pour
certains ont été tués je le rappelle on
est un pays on a tué des policiers et
des policières en service tué tué on est
un pays où il ya des gens qui chargent
en voiture quand il un policier donc
j'essaie juste de vous faire comprendre
que quand il ya des gens qui vous
paraissent avoir un comportement violent
avec un individu c'est aussi parce
qu'ils ont vu des collègues se faire
brûler dans une voiture se faire
caillasser se faire tirer au mortier se
faire tirer à balles réelles
c'est aussi parce que parfois ils vivent
une réalité et ce sont aussi vous ou vos
auditeurs ou les a beaucoup
membre de votre communauté ce sont des
gens dans les gamins sont emmerdés à
l'école pardon de parler comme ça les
enfants sont harcelés par les autres
enfants accusés parce que les parents
sont policiers tout a lancé il explique
c'est inexcusable et en fait là vous
trouvez d expliquer non non je suis pas
en train de trouver des explications
c'est justement là où c'est on a
toujours ce même problème parce que
comment le jeu doit être nuancée parce
qu'on considérait qu'on mettrait le
balancier de commander vous avez vous
une société à une autre mais non mais
justement je sais je suis en train
d'essayer de faire inverse
aidez moi je suis en train de dire que
parce qu'on est policier on doit être
absolument irréprochable respecter une
déontologie et de là où je suis moi je
dois être intraitable avec les policiers
mais si on est juste je suis pas en
train d'expliquer je dis soyons justes
on a ce que vivent sur le terrain les
policiers et les policiers peut parfois
déclenchées ça ça n'excuse en rien ça
peut parfois l'expliquer ça doit nous
conduire aussi à dire on a tous une
responsabilité nous en tant que citoyens
ne pas participer à la violence
collective et en tant que journalistes
participants du débat public de savoir
aussi être juste en disant où est la
violence dans la société et tous
ensemble d'essayer de la réduire
et moi je pense que les ferments de la
violence ils sont dans la main de
quelques milliers dans notre pays c'est
pas beaucoup les black blocks et les
gens qui sont radicaux dans la
radicaliser dans la violence urbaine
évidemment la violence terroriste on
n'en a pas parlé jusqu'à l'or mais qui
est la plus terrible et celles et ceux
qui mènent les trafics et conduisent les
violences en ville actuellement au coeur
des débats et c'est d'ailleurs les
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux il
ya plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
nous ont encore envoyer des questions
c'est dans les buts et on les salue on
salue toute la communauté brut qui n'ont
rien activement et qui nous fait
remonter toutes ces questions et
notamment celles autour de l'article 24
ce projet de loi sécurité globale ya
beaucoup de contestations manifestation
je rappelle que c'est un article qui
vise à protéger les policiers en
limitant la diffusion d'image des forces
de l'ordre l'intervention on nous
annonce que ce texte sera réécrit c'est
ce que vous avez évoqué en début de
semaine est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
tout simplement le supprimer
d'abord je pense que c'est bien
j'entends beaucoup de gens parler de
liberté de démocratie
c'est bien de respecter dans une
démocratie la constitution est justement
toutes les libertés
il s'agit d'un texte qui est une
proposition de loi
c'est à dire c'est un texte qui émane de
l'assemblée nationale vos députés comme
vos sénateurs peuvent proposer des
textes pour changer la loi et qui fait
des remous au sein même de la majorité
non mais c'est normal qu'ils fassent des
remous c'est le débat démocratique
honnêtement les les remous comme vous
dites les controverses les discussions
c'est une très bonne chose
ce qui est inacceptable c'est la
violence est ce que justement la finale
et donc le sida mais les suppressions
cet article c'est une question mais je
vous réponds juste la fois sûr d'abord
sur le processus sont des parlementaires
qui propose ce texte ils ont voté en
première lecture
celles et ceux qui l'ont voté voyant les
mois parfois la colère l'incompréhension
disent on va le changer cet article 24
on va le réécrire parce que il lève une
ambiguïté d'abord il faut le laisser
vivre sa vie démocratique on est dans
une démocratie ce n'est pas
l'indignation de chacun chaque jour qui
chante qui fait les lois donc ce texte
maintenant il valait au sénat les
sénateurs vont pouvoir eux mêmes
l'enrichir l'amendé et reviendra à
l'assemblée et à ce moment là ils
pourrons réécrire et et continuer à se
nourrir aussi d'un vrai débat
démocratique sur comment justement on
traite de ces sujets de violence comment
on traite du fonctionnement de la police
dans une société on doit préserver
toutes nos libertés réduire la violence
c'est ça ce qu'ils ont voulu fermer donc
dans ce texte comporte donc mieux
pourquoi j'ai cette prudence parce que
contrairement à un projet de loi c'est
pas un texte qui est venu sur la table
du conseil des ministres que le
président de la république et des
ministres valide c'est un texte que en
quelque sorte institutionnellement je
n'ai pas eu à connaître encore ce texte
il a soulevé beaucoup d'interrogations
justement parlons très franchement très
clairement plusieurs questions qui se
posent à l'est la première tout citoyen
tout journaliste pourra-t-il continuer
affirmé les forces de l'ordre
demain oui quelques en quoi qu'il arrive
oui pourra-t-il toujours le diffuser sur
les réseaux sociaux journalistes comme
citoyen alors ça c'est la grande
question car c'est là où juste bien sûr
je pense que la réponse sera oui de
toute façon soyons clairs nous sommes
dans un monde ouvert demain on veut
l'interdire et en france trouvez quoi
vous le transférer vous fait émettre
depuis la belgique ou l'italie
c'est pas interdit mais déjà certains se
sont proposés de faire donc la réponse
est oui donc diffusion toujours garantie
pour tout le monde c'est à dire que
parce que on a entendu même parfois des
propos du médiator jardin
mais qu'est ce qu'il a coûté qu'est ce
qu'il a dit le ministre
d'ailleurs il a aussi revenons à ce
qu'on veut faire pour essayer tous de
trouver une solution dans sortir par le
haut mais ils ont l'intérieur il a dit
ce qui est légitime
juste c'est son rôle il a dit on doit
protéger les policiers et les gendarmes
et il a raison parce qu'aujourd'hui
comme je le disais certains sont ensuite
poursuivis leurs familles sont harcelés
et ils sont dans une situation
d'insécurité et donc je partage les
objectifs
il ya déjà des textes de loi pour ça
qu'ils disent voilà si demain je fais
une publication où je publie un policier
que je veux l'insultent je peux être et
bunge appel à la violence il y en a mais
qui sont pas suffisamment d'une part
appliquer d'autres parcs dont le système
n'est pas complet mais on va y revenir
donc l'objectif je le partage mieux
protégés dans un monde qui est devenu
beaucoup plus violent où la viralité
parfois de certaines images est devenu
une arme
ce que je ne veux pas c'est que pour
pour atteindre cet objectif on réduise
des libertés quelle qu'elle soit est là
et je pense très sincèrement que les
parlementaires pourquoi j'ai cette
prudence parce que moi pas comme comme
on disait avant moi président je vais
pas m'immiscer dans un débat à
l'assemblée nationale c'est pas c'est
pas mon rôle je suis le garant des
institutions je n'ai pas à m'immiscer
dans un texte de loi mais je vous le dis
très clairement je souscris à l'objectif
de mieux protéger des forces de l'ordre
je pense qu'on peut améliorer le
dispositif le gouvernement a travaillé
dans le cadre de la loi
justement pour réaffirmer l'application
des principes républicains
il a travaillé un texte qui permet de
mieux protéger d'ailleurs les forces de
l'ordre et également d'autres
fonctionnaires qui sont très exposés
aujourd'hui de par leur mission je pense
que c'est mieux d'y arriver comme ça et
par la sanction
cette voie était suivi qui consistait à
dire non pas d'ailleurs flouté interdire
etc
mais pour les non journalistes en effet
créé des limites quand on voit les mois
les sacres et je pense que c'est pas
nous on est tous en train de se le dire
c'est pas une bonne c'est pas un bon
chemin donc je peux très facilement vous
dire demain les journalistes les
citoyens pourront continuer à diffuser
avoir d'assumer diffusé oui parce qu on
est dans un système un pays de liberté
on ne peut pas réduire
donc ça c'est le garantis vous pouvez
prendre aujourd'hui parce que ça que ça
pas été compris comme ce jour là mais
mon sens de l'annoncé pour ça que c'est
pour ça que les parlementaires eux mêmes
ont dit on va le réécrire donc un oui
nous devons renforcer la sécurité des
forces de l'ordre et en particulier des
policiers dans le cadre des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre
parce qu'aujourd'hui ils sont parfois
mises en danger par certains
situation et ça on doit ensemble traité
démocratiquement 2,7
la réponse à apporter ne peut pas être
en réduisant encadrant les libertés
d'expression en particulier la liberté
de la presse est là je crois très
sincèrement que ça n'a jamais été
atteint je veux ici le dire très
clairement beaucoup de sensibilités
politiques différentes ont voté le texte
en première lecture
alors je crois pouvoir dire que ça n'a
jamais été leur intention il ya une
incompréhension un débat jean partir
toutes les conséquences de cette raison
le débat il est aussi international
et bien sûr et les images de violences
policières contre des manifestants
contre des journalistes contre rémy par
exemple elles ont choqué donc on a vu en
france à juste titre mais aussi dans le
monde entier et depuis plusieurs
semaines vous avez sûrement vu la presse
étrangères notamment anglo saxonne qui
s'inquiète d'une dérive autoritaire de
votre part et bien souvent nourries par
autre chose alors on va en voir avant ça
vous fait quoi vous en tout cas pour une
partie du monde d'être passé en 2017 le
président moderne libéral à président
autoritaire c'est ce que ça vous blesse
est ce que ça vous arrange d'abord je
suis pas là pour donner mes états d'âme
et quand on a lu tout ce que j'ai pu
lire sur moi en france ou à l'étranger
ne sont plus ça mais ça m'est égal en
touche pas non mais ça m'est égal je
fais pas s'est passé je ne fais pas ce
que je fais
l'image de la france c'est comme
importante mais nous en sommes
coresponsables quand on a aussi des
journalistes qui diffuse des
objectivement des informations qui sont
fausses et sur ce débat on a dit
beaucoup de bêtises sur ce débat on a
prêté aux législateurs beaucoup de
bêtises et quand je vois beaucoup de
correspondants étrangers faisant
référence à des journées à des
journalistes ou autres qui sont des
quasi militants et utiliser cela pour
dire c'est ce qui est en train de faire
la france
on a créé une bulle où on a en quelque
sorte expliqué qu'en france on allait
réduire toutes les libertés
très sincèrement ça n'a jamais été
l'intention du législateur et tant que
je suis là ce ne sera pas ce qu'on fera
je vous le dis très clairement comme je
voulais dis là est donc quelque part il
ya une coproduction de cette image de la
france
donc j'invite tout le monde à la
responsabilité et lyon tous les débats
utiles et lyon laissant les caricatures
et ayant les sans abîmer l'image de
notre pays parce que je pense que quand
on regarde aujourd'hui le pays est ce
qu'on est un pays où la liberté de
manifester et en étant risque
non il n'y a pas un pays où il paye il
ya eu plus de manifestations que le
nôtre il n'y a pas eu un pays où malgré
parfois la violence qui avait dans ses
manifestations manuel contexte sanitaire
on a préservé cette liberté est ce que
nous sommes un pays où la liberté de la
presse est remise en cause
non ça a été le cas ces derniers temps
des journalistes min et placée en garde
aux manifestants suivi des jeunes en
raison des entraves fois attendait leur
travail je suis moi je suis le premier
je suis le premier à le défendre c'est
pour ça que je compte demander au
gouvernement de lancer cette mission
pour justement que ces choses là soient
clarifiées le ministre de l'intérieur a
eu aussi en répondre pour beaucoup
plusieurs en tout cas de ces
journalistes qui ont été placés dans ces
situations pour certains ils n'avaient
pas leurs cartes de presse avec la carte
de presse n'est pas au moment où les
français n'avaient pas eu d'autre mettez
vous à la place des policiers il avait
il avait en espèces pour jeunesse de
france - il avait un coeur de presse
mais il n'était pas en train d'exercer
sa mission je veux pas commenter tel ou
tel ou tel ou tel cas mais ces
désignations de terrain quand même
qu'ils peuvent rien sur mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour revenir sur un
débat technique que vous connaissez très
bien il ya un schéma national de
maintien de l'ordre avec des règles de
relations presse forces de l'ordre qui
existe depuis 2012 2012 on est toujours
dans l'application de ce schéma est
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'ils posent
des problèmes parce que la pratique
d'abord du journalisme a changé vous en
est un exemple vivant mais au-delà de ce
qui est brut
il ya aussi beaucoup d'indépendants qui
rentre dans le journée et qu' il faut
pouvoir protéger toutes ces pratiques
aient la capacité à informer dans le
pays et donc ce qui pose aussi des
problèmes par rapport à ce schéma
national à ce que font les forces de
l'ordre en particulier au moment il faut
siffler la fin des manifestations donc
c'est des sujets très compliqué
d'organisation si on veut réussir il
faut reposer les termes points 1 point
et réussir à dire comment la police peut
faire son travail qui est un travail qui
consiste à sécuriser une manifestation
empêcher les dégradations parce que
comme vous je tiens à l'ordre
républicain et comment on s'assure que
tous les journalistes puissent être
protégés et faire leur travail dans de
bonnes conditions dans les manifs
aujourd'hui la situation n'est pas
satisfaisante mais c'est pas pardon
c'est pas ça qui fait d'un et un état
autoritaire alors c'est là où je dis que
c'est un grand mensonge alors je devrais
dire qu'on n'est pas la hongrie la
turquie ou autres à la turque l'on tire
et à votre meilleur allemand attendait
absolue car doit juste finir sur ce
point donc là dessus qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va mettre en place une mission
que lance le premier ministre avec notre
hôte le ministre de l'intérieur garde
des sceaux et la ministre de la culture
qui est en charge des médias pour
pouvoir
là-dessus apporter des réponses très
pratique et qu'on trouve en quelque
sorte le bon le bon code des usages pour
que toutes ces minutes c'est la remplit
exactement mais ce que je trouve c'est
qu'on a eu un débat les esprits se sont
échauffés
très honnêtement sur tout sujet je le
respecte la réponse je crois a été
apportée moi je vous apporte aujourd'hui
toute la clarté mais derrière
ne laissons pas la france d'être
caricaturé et là encore je pense qu'on
se laisse contaminé par un discours
militant très hostile à l'action du
gouvernement et à votre serviteur que je
respecte celle dans le jeu des
oppositions politiques messi s'il
devient le discours général très
sincèrement en france est-ce que les
libertés sont réduites on a décidé de
les réduire pour faire face à l'épidémie
ça oui malheureusement pour nous tous et
je suis le premier à le à le regretter
mais c'est ce qui nous a permis de tenir
et de la casser cette idée me mets sur
les autres sujets jeu je peux pas
laisser dire qu'on réduit les libertés
dans notre pays et je peux pas dire qui
a pas de débat démocratique parfois un
peu vibrant en tout cas moi j'en serai
toujours le garant mais nous sommes
aujourd'hui face à des violences qui
sont parfois inédites face à des risques
nouveaux on l'a eue lviv pour le
terrorisme et il faut construire dans le
cadre de nos voilà deux de nos libertés
de notre droit les moyens d'y répondre
monsieur le président tout à l'heure
vous m'avez coupé quand j'allais parler
d'autres bajrami red chef d'état hyper
doan je prononce bien oui il a exprimé
vous avez peut-être vu aujourd'hui
l'espoir de voir la france et les
français
pardonnez-moi se débarrasser le plus tôt
possible de vous qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez moi je n'ai jamais moi je ne
suis jamais rentré dans la réponse admin
m
c'est ce qui nous différencie je crois
dans le respect je pense que je suis en
train de dire que nos sociétés sont de
plus en plus violente
elles le sont aussi parce que les
dirigeants donner un exemple de violence
et donc je pense que l'invectivé entre
dirigeants politiques et n'est pas la
bonne méthode
je je ça me permet de dire par rapport à
la presse anglo saxonne un sur deux chez
je trouve qu'il ya une forme de paradoxe
on on m'a attaqué à l'étranger on a
attaqué la france nous attaquent sur les
libertés
il n'y a pas un pays comme nous qui à
protéger la liberté d'expression dans la
période récente
après l attaque terroriste que nous
avons subies
et qui a conduit à l'assassinât de sa
mère pattie partout partout s'est levé
il n'aurait pas dû ils ont exagéré
ils sont allés trop loin ils ont insulté
et on a remis en cause notre liberté
d'expression et la france a été attaquée
parce que nous avons défendu la liberté
d'expression parce que j'ai en effet pas
simplement défendu cet enseignant mais
toutes celles et ceux qui critiquent qui
peuvent baisser mais conformément à
notre droit qui conteste parce que nous
sommes dans une société où la liberté
d'expression est et la pleine et entière
pourquoi parce qu'il ya justement ce
cadre de respect parce que vous pouvez
me répondre me contester apportez votre
vérité mais qu'à aucun moment je ne vais
vous interdire cette liberté et je ne
vais justifier la violence au nom du
fait que je vous choque
on a été très seul moi j'ai été frappée
que très peu d'intellectuels et parfois
deux journalistes français ont
accompagné mon accompagne dans ce combat
silence très peu
j'ai été frappée que la presse anglo
saxonne a même dit ces français sont
étranges ils ont insulté le prophète il
n'aime pas l'islam c'est un problème
avec cette religion est donc quelque
chose et encore quand même en train de
bouger qui est une forme de d'ordre
moral nouveau qui consiste à dire il ya
des choses où on peut justifier la
liberté c'est ça le vrai combat
existentiel pour nous tous pour nos
générations beaucoup plus que l'article
24 permettez moi de vous le dire parce
que l'article 24 quand bien même il
aurait été ce qu'on en a décrit il était
au mieux inopérant au mieux parce que
tout le monde aurait été maîtres je le
disais depuis la belgique ou ailleurs
donc on se trompe de vrais débats mais
on n'a pas été à sept combattants de la
vraie liberté d'expression face à la
turquie de monsieur erdogan et se
distingue toujours sa présidence et son
gouvernement du peuple turc qui aiment
la liberté qui est un grand peuple de
liberté et de toutes celles et ceux qui
ont parfois à subir ces violences et ces
restrictions de liberté c'est ça la
france sur le pour l'instant on a des
dizaines de milliers de commentaires
50000 commentaire il ya un sujet qui
remonte beaucoup c'est une loi qui va
apparaître qui va être discutée dans
quelques jours une loi qui s'appelait au
départ loi
c'est parra sur le séparatisme et qui
s'appelle désormais vous en avez vous en
avez un diamant tout à l'heure la loi
confortant les principes républicains
une loi qui vise à lutter contre ce que
vous avez appelé le séparatisme
islamistes alors les principes
républicains moi ça me parle j'ai été
prof longtemps d'histoire-géo notamment
en seine-saint-denis g avec fall âge de
samuel jati j'enseigne à mes élèves de
seconde la méditerranée carrefour de
civilisations au 12e siècle
j'ai donné des cours d'éducation civique
à mes élèves et puis un jour j'ai ouvert
le journal et dans le journal j'ai
découvert qu'un de mes élèves avaient
basculé dans le djihadisme
c'est un élève qui aujourd'hui purge une
peine de prison longue ça ne laisse que
j'ai eu dans ma classe qui était à
l'école de la république
et depuis ce jour là je peux vous dire
que je ne cesse de me demander comment
ça a été possible et je me pose aussi
une question personnelle qu'est ce que
j'ai raté en tant qu'enseignant qu'est
ce que l'école a raté et cette question
je vous la pose est ce que vous la poser
à vous aussi cette question qu'est ce
qu'on a raté
bien sûr je m'impose savez j'ai en
novembre 2015
j'avais d'ailleurs je m'étais exprimé en
disant c'est une part de nous ceux qui
ont fait le bataclan parce qu' ils sont
là ils étaient là et le le jeune homme
qui a été assassinée qui a commis cet
acte terroriste l'égard de sa mère
pattie était certes d'origine étrangère
mais il était sur le sol français depuis
qu'il était tout petit et on a
énormément de deux françaises deux
français qui en effet vont vers les
extrêmes et jusqu'à commettre l'acte
terroriste et donc je dis ça parce que
beaucoup de gens font énormément de
confusion le mal il est en nous le mal
des temps nous c'est pas vrai de dire
qu'on ne chassera par un coût de 1 coup
de baguette ou une action unique ou
extrêmement musclé et donc quelque chose
s'est installée dans nos dans nos
civilisations dans nos sociétés qui fait
que certains de nos jeunes ou moins
jeunes sont attirés par d'abord quelque
chose qui va en effet les séparer du
commun cc j'ai voulu parler de
séparatisme pour parler de
communautarisme pour parce qu'on ne me
faisais souvent cette confusion
c'est à dire c'est rejoindre une
idéologie ou on vous dit que nos valeurs
en particulier cette idéologie islamiste
et pas islamique islamistes c'est à dire
celles et ceux qui utilisent en la
religion qu'est l'islam font une
idéologie qui consiste à dire les
valeurs de la république sont plus les
miennes je ne crois plus entre l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes et les
hommes
je vais sortir ma fille est de l'école
je vais la voilée intégralement je vais
avoir des pratiques plus que rigoriste
je vais justifier des actes de violence
et il ya un moment si je puis dire toute
une série de facteurs qui vient de
s'enclencher
il ya un projet celui de cette idéologie
islamiste
celui qu'on veut combattre et que cette
loi va chercher à tout cas pas sur
lequel on veut mieux se réarmer pour
dissoudre les associations lutter contre
celles et ceux qui portent cette
idéologie mais cette idéologie elles
prospèrent sur nos échecs sur ce qu'on a
mal fait sur votre réflexion professeur
et qui je peux vous dire tous les jours
ma réflexion de président et celle que
j'avais avant comme citoyen parce que le
même enseignant vous avez parlé de voûte
semaine pâtit moi ce qui m'a bouleversé
c'est que ça man pâtit faisait l'été
d'avant son cours chez ses parents à
moulins il s'appelle pâtissent était pas
à quelqu'un qui ne voulait pas
comprendre l'islam
il avait noué une relation avec
l'institut du monde arabe pour justement
comprendre les choses emmené ses élèves
fin donc il savait cela il se pose et je
pense ces mêmes questions mais c'est que
ceux qui mènent cette idéaux qui ont
cette idéologie et d'un prospère sur
quoi sur nos échecs et nos échecs c'est
le ressentiment qui est né dans une
partie de la population pour des raisons
culturelles historiques
c'est à dire l'échec de l'intégration à
la française pourrait revenir mais qui
étiez une construction imaginaire qui au
fond qu'est ce que c'est qu'être
français et on a laissé à beaucoup de
nos jeunes et moins jeunes l'idée qu' il
n'était pas une part de france et là
dessus celles et ceux qui ont ce projet
la vienne les chercher des intérêts
n'était pas une part de france justement
vient retrouver mon projet juste juste
pour finir il ya ya ensuite leur
sentiment économique et social c'est ces
discriminations alors ça on va à l'angle
gauche au logement
elles nourrissent ce ressentiment est un
roman tout ça rien là c'est pareil le
même réponse que je sais tout seul tout
à l'heure rien de tous ces facteurs ne
justifie ni ne permet d
c'est le terrorisme mais il permet de
l'expliquer pour partie et de le
déconstruire et donc oui on à l'hydre
terroriste qui est là mais il ya
maintenant s'en aller juste cette
idéologie et tous ces problèmes que la
france à s'en aller jusqu'au terrorisme
vous avez depuis votre arrivée au
pouvoir et même un petit peu avant en
campagne une forme d'obsession sans
vouloir caricaturer vos propos pour
essayer de parler à ces français qui ne
se reconnaissent pas ou plus dans la
république c'est la mémoire le travail
sur la mémoire et en particulier la
guerre d'algérie benjamin stora à vous
rendre un rapport dans quelques jours et
en particulier la décolonisation est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer le lien
que vous faites entre cette période de
notre histoire de france
et ces jeunes déboussolés de notre
république d'aujourd'hui je sais pas
dire si nos jeunes sont déboussolés je
pense qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
exigeants pas sentiment d'être vieux
mais que de l'été ma génération
ça c'est sûr que cette génération qui a
20 ans aujourd'hui comme je disais
qu'ils vilcot vide et qui est là quand
même faut mesurer ce qu'elle s'est pris
c'est la génération qui est née avec le
le terrorisme des tours qui s'est pris
l'une des plus grandes crises
économiques et financières jusqu'à
maintenant 2007 2008 qui a pris le
terrorisme qui est la génération qui a
eu à connaître la conscience du drame
climatique et qui maintenant vie à la
fois le à nouveau le terrorisme qui
revient dans notre pays la plus grande
pandémie qu'on est à vivre depuis ces
dernières décennies
donc il ya même de quoi se poser des
questions personnelles et géopolitique
mêlez pas déboussolés elle est en
recherche de sens moi je pense que notre
société
enfin en particulier notre pays qui est
ce rapport très particulier à l'afrique
à l'histoire n'a pas pensé son passé et
c'est pas non plus une culture de
l'excusé comme certains disent une
culture de la vérité
nous avons des millions de nos jeunes et
moins jeunes qui sont issus soit en
première génération deuxième ou
troisième du continent africain
et je pense qu'on a pas su leur parler
leurs parents sont souvent venus
d'ailleurs pour des raisons économiques
pour aider à reconstruire la france pour
refaire les métiers les plus ingrats
qu'on ne voulait plus faire on l'a pas
toujours d'ailleurs très bien reconnus
et traités pas formidablement intégrer
on les a souvent mis dans les mêmes
quartiers
c'est là moi ce qui m'a toujours frappé
c'est leurs parents sont venus parler
très peu de décolonisation leurs grands
parents
quand leur mère ou leur grand-mère sont
venues elles n'étaient pas voilées et
parfois même elles se sont dévoilés en
arrivant en france et on a une
génération qui reparle de colonisation
alors qu'elle ne l'a jamais vécu et que
l es né en france et qui justement aussi
se revoient leur trouvera construit au
fond une appartenance à quelque chose et
reconstruit cette appartenance à quelque
chose parce que nous la république la
nation française n'a pas su lui dire tu
as une place là tuez nous et ça c'est
notre ère et moi je pense qu'on est on
est à la génération quand je dis la
génération là je suis un peu tous les
âges mais on est à la génération qui
doit dépasser ça d'abord en regardant
notre passé dans tout ça avec les
historiens par les historiens de manière
très réelle qu'est ce que c'est la
colonisation je me suis déjà exprimé ma
de manière très directe sur ce sujet je
pense qu'il faut savoir le dire le vivre
nous ne sommes pas un pays qui comme les
états unis a vécu la ségrégation
on a vécu le projet colonial c'est autre
chose c'est un autre problème
mais on a parfois eu des gens sur notre
sol dont on à qui on donnait pas la
citoyenneté est justement pour revenir à
vos propositions concrètes shônen qui
est très commentée c'est celle de
l'enseignement de l'arabe à l'école
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
cela c'est un peu en confiance aux
conflits aux confins des deux mais je
vais je vais revenir pour repréciser ce
que je disais à l'instant on a des
énormément de jeunes qui dont les
familles parlent arabe
parfois les deux parents dont la culture
familiale et en langue arabe
ils apprennent à la république dans
l'école de la république où l'école
privée sous contrat ou l'école privée le
français et ils vont quand même parce
qu'à cette demande ce besoin ils vont
continuer à apprendre
ou à perfectionner leur leur langue et
leur langue maternelle ou une langue
familiale du coup à l'extérieur parce
que la république leur offre peu de
langue d'enseignement en arabe on est en
train d'améliorer les choses
les chiffres s'améliorent et donc il ya
beaucoup d'associations qui l'offrent ça
c'est très bien mais ces associations
sont souvent le lieu
je caricature pas c'est pas toujours le
cas loin de là mais elles sont parfois
le lieu de celles et ceux qui au fond en
même temps vont leur expliquer un projet
séparatiste c'est à dire une idéologie
et utilise l'enseignement de l'arabe
pour les détourner de la république et
moi je crois à la une ce que
j'appellerais une politique de
reconnaissance
quand vous connaissez l'arabe ou que
votre famille parle arabe en france
c'est une chance pour la france ça a
quelque chose à apporter à notre pays
dans la vie de tous les jours pour
connaître la littérature pour l'enseigné
à d'autres pour pouvoir voyager pour
pouvoir commercer pour rendre le pays
plus fort on apprend tous des langues
étrangères est en quelque sorte on a
refoulé les langues étrangères de celles
et ceux qui étaient issus d'autres pays
ou qui appartenaient à des diasporas
c'est vraiment un processus de
refoulement et dans le pays qui est en
train de continuer à s'améliorer le
doigt sur les langues étrangères
on ne regarde pas un potentiel
extraordinaire qu'on a c'est qu'on a des
jeunes qui en effet parle arabe arabe
littéraire ou dialectal qu'on a des
jeunes qui savent parler pour d'autres
le haoussa où beaucoup d'autres dernier
direct africains qui dans un continent
en explosion et une chance inouïe
si on veut pouvoir justement réussira
mieux le comprendre et mieux faire qui
parle le turc qui vont savoir parler un
tas de langues
justement absolument infinie et 1 on ne
reconnaît pas de on ne lance n y pas
suffisamment et donc moi ce que je veux
faire en effet c'est pouvoir remettre de
l'enseignement de l'arabe qui lui nous
le sait des langues les plus parlées par
ces jeunes et à leurs familles dans la
république pour éviter que ce soient
détournées par d'autres mais aussi pour
reconnaître cette part mais par rapport
à ce que vous disiez la mémoire et le
ces sujets de de décolonisation je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a à finir le travail
historique sur la guerre d'algérie c'est
la mission demander à benjamin stora qui
est un travail
histoire sur l'effet d'ouverture des
archives un travail aussi pour que nos
manuels rendent compte de toute cette
période et un travail qui permettra du
coup la réconciliation des mémoires
parce que nous avons dans notre pays des
tas de mémoire de la guerre d'algérie
qui sont autant de blessures qu'il faut
tout respecter les enfants issus de
l'immigration est d'origine algérienne
ou binationaux ou français mais dans les
grands parents étaient algériens les
harkis et leurs enfants
les pieds noirs et leurs enfants les
appelés du contingent les militaires il
ya au moins cinq ou six mémoire blessée
simplement de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée de cet épisode
si on ne leur met pas en perspective
pour le comprendre et avoir une histoire
partagée ses mémoires ne se parlent plus
et moi je pense qu'il est très important
c'est justement d'expliquer à toute
cette jeunesse qui se cherche de dire la
république d'abord vous reconnaît vous
reconnais vous êtes des enfants de cette
république et vous êtes une chance pour
elle et donc votre histoire individuelle
est une partie de notre histoire
collective le fond quand on parle
d'identité française cette identité
c'est la grande histoire qu'on connaît
tous mais c'est aussi des tas
d'histoires très c'est que toute cette
jeunesse porte par son aventure
familiale et donc il faut savoir
reconnaître ses mémoires les partager et
donc la reconnaître dans nos programmes
d'histoire beaucoup mieux qu'on ne le
fait la reconnaître dans nos musées la
reconnaître aussi il est où ce débat sur
les statuts parfois on m'a dit c'est une
brute épaisse parce qu'il ya dix ans
déboulonnera pas les statuts en france
moi je crois pas à ce qu'on appelle là
quand cette culture crois pas l'idée
qu'on efface ce qu'on est par contre ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'il ya toute une
part de notre histoire collective qui
n'est pas représenté il ya toute une
partie de notre histoire qui parle à une
jeunesse qui est noir qui est d'ailleurs
noire venant d'afrique ou noir ultra
marines avec d'autres relation à
l'afrique parce qu'elle est en plus
connu une commerce triangulaire d'autres
formes de deuxième elle a connu un lien
l'esclavagé la république malgré vite et
ils ont leur héros simplement on ne les
a pas reconnues on n'aura pas donné une
place qui par exemple on aimerait avoir
une statue de qui à paris c'est pas
alors pour le coup moi j'ai plein
d'idées
non mais je vais pas je vais vous dire
c'est précisément pas à moi de le dire
moi j'avais commencé à dire il ya le
père dumas qui est formidable général de
l' empire qui était mulâtre il a
totalement oublié mais le père
d'alexandre dumas et les mulâtres et il
s'installe à villers cotterêts et
s'éteint c'est un héros de guerre n'a
totalement oublié sa statue à paris elle
a existé elle a été déboulonnée il ya
des décennies mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est là où je dis c'est pas à
moi de le dire c'est que ce serait une
forme de geste officiel
ce que je voudrais par rapport à tout ce
qu'on sait tous qu'on se dit c'est que
justement les historiens mais aussi
notre jeunesse et toutes celles et ceux
qui ceux qui se retrouvent dans ces
histoires un peu fragmentée fracturée
mais qui pour moi sont une richesse
parce que ce sont des histoires en fait
avec plein d'harmoniques qu'ils puissent
les choisir votre collègue pascal
blanchard a commencé à faire ce travail
avec d'autres pap ndiaye plusieurs
autres ont aussi contribué réfléchi moi
je j'aimerais qu'il y ait une forme
d'appel à la contribution collective et
qu' on essaie d'identifier 300 à 500
noms alors et que d'ici au mois de mars
ont lésé on puisse avoir non mais il a
commencé donc on va le finir mais je
voudrais que ce soit nourrie par aussi
par le voir toute la jeunesse et on sent
qu'ils ont une conscience civique et
qu'au mois de mars on puisse avoir une
espèce de catalogue des 300 ou 500 noms
hockey de ses héros elle qu'on puisse
décider ensuite d'en faire des rues des
statuts d c'est comme ça que les choses
changent il faudra donc changer quelques
noms de rues mais sans avoir ce débat
maintenant oui il ya des tas de choses à
refaire il y aura des murs eu de
nombreux échanges et il ya des cités
nouvelles refaire mais je pense c'est
très important
mais là veulent juste vivre une autre
histoire elle est la conjugaison toutes
ces histoires vous avez dit l'arabe est
l'école vous avez dit les manuels
scolaires dont l'école est donc un lieu
évidemment et ces travaux vous allez
apprendre ou la république où la
dimension de citoyens se construit parmi
les mesures de cette loi
confortant les principes républicains il
y en a une il ya une mesure dont on
parle beaucoup
d'ailleurs des gens sont dans la rue
demain pour s'y opposer c'est le
contrôle de l'école à la maison vous
voulez qu'on fasse plus d'école à la
maison sauf pour des raisons médicales
il ya une question de lydia qui nous dit
l'instruction en famille c'est son vrai
nom est une richesse de pratique
pédagogique déjà contrôlée et encadrée
par l'état
pourquoi l'amalgamé avec des écoles
clandestines
des enfants non déclarés ou des
terroristes
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez à l'ina
ou évidemment veut pas l'amalgamé mais
c'est un peu comme le problème ont
évoqué tout à l'heure on a un objectif
et vu parfois il ya des effets de bord
est donc faut lever cette ambiguïté
qu'est ce que c'est l'objectif c'est de
lutter contre justement ces groupes ces
associations est derrière ces personnes
qui ont une idéologie qui au nom de
cette idéologie veulent sortir de la
république
séparés en particulier des jeunes on a
fermé récemment en région parisienne
plusieurs écoles de ce type école jeudi
c'est entre guillemets qui sont des
établissements où on fête les enfants
étaient déclarés comme recevant un
enseignement à la maison ce qui est
possible par la luz le président ça on a
compris mais juste mais oui mais donc
comment vous voulez faire pour éviter là
qu'ils ont à l'action aujourd'hui comme
la crise opposée pour les autres valeurs
ni même rien à prouver donc les bonnes
d'aix et voilà mais ce qui est très je
veux que vous compreniez pourquoi on
fait ça parce que dans les quartiers les
plus sensibles
on a de plus en plus de camions parable
c'est-à-dire d'abord il ya le père ou la
mère qui va arriver qui va dire il a pu
aller à la piscine où elle va plus à la
piscine elle va arrêter le cours de
musique vous parler des autres cas non
mais c'est très important de comprendre
déjà ce qu'on veut faire et puis après
je vais vous expliquer comment on traite
les autres excepté faut qu'on avance
pardon mais tout ça c'est des problèmes
tellement important d'accord moi j'ai
tout mon temps et donc est donc ce qui
est trés ce qui est très important c'est
ça si on réagit pas on va avoir une
inflation de ces cas et qui sont à quoi
on a assisté ces cons à pousser des
portes de quelque chose qui était pas du
tout une école qu'on ne connaissait pas
qu'ils étaient des des lieux tenus par
des associations parce que on a repéré
qu'il y avait des parents qui arrivent
avec des enfants chaque jour qui avait
des gens qui étaient en niqab intégral
etc
on l'ouvré on a des fillettes qui sont
en voile intégral qui sont assises par
terre qui ont pas droit de dessiner des
visages à qui on apprend justement pas
le français mais que l'arabe et à qui on
apprend des des préceptes qui ne sont
mêmes qui sont complètement contraire
aux lois de la république aujourd'hui
face à ça qu'est ce qu'on fait on ne
peut fermer ces structures que sur des
raisons sanitaires ou de sécurité
on ne peut pas les fermer au titre de la
loi et donc on doit la fermer
grâce ce sera la loi qui arrive donc ce
qu'il faut simplement faire c'est
prévoir les bonnes exception pour que
quand on a les garanties qui est un bon
encadrement à la maison des bonnes
évidemment que s'est imposée par des
conditions de santé mais ça c'est ce que
le ministre de l'éducation va travailler
il a commencé avec le conseil d'état et
va continuer avec les parlementaires
faut que les bonnes exception qui
correspondent aux situations que les
gens vivent et qui correspond à une
liberté légitime conforme aux valeurs de
la république puisse continuer à se
faire donc je rassure et deux gars c'est
pas du tout empêché de faire ce qu'elle
fait aujourd'hui mais c'est nous donner
des armes pour que face à ce que je
viens de vous décrire qui est pour moi
quelque chose que je ne veux pas voir
dans notre république et kim président
comment on le ferme et pas simplement
parce que quelques vides ou parce que
c'est parce qu'il ya une question qui
remonte beaucoup aussi c'est la critique
de l'islam
vous connaissez la ferme il a le cas de
la jeune miley c'est une adolescente de
17 ans elle a violemment critiqué
l'islam sur les réseaux sociaux et
depuis elle est menacée de mort elle vit
cachée elle a quitté son lycée
comment on peut en arriver là en france
en 2001 parce que nous avons aujourd'hui
une situation qui est une situation là
aussi de violences permanentes qui donne
le fait que quand une jeune fille va
dans une émission de variétés grand
public chanter avec le voile elle est
conspué et elle doit partir mais neil et
que quand vous avez une jeune fille qui
critiquent l'islam sur les réseaux
sociaux elle est harcelée elle ne peut
même plus est dans une école mais là ça
veut dire qu'on est devenu fou c'est ça
le sujet et que les gens ne respectent
pas un principe fondamental la
république qu'est ce qu'on appelle la
laïcité c'est à dire le fait que vous
pouvez en france croire ou ne pas croire
librement que la seule chose que je vous
demande c'est de respecter totalement
les lois de la république et qu'en
france on peut en effet critiqué
absolument tout président de la
république gouvernement les journalistes
une religion que c'est pas une atteinte
aux libertés ou quelque chose qui choque
c'est un droit une liberté profonde et
donc on peut pas faire une loi
on va faire une loi qui réduit ça mais
ça vous montre là aussi ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure une autre forme de
violence dans la société et le le le
moins bon visage des réseaux sociaux
celui du harcèlement à l'école et celui
du harcèlement au tour justement de la
violence qui s'est installée autour de
de la religion et en particulier de
l'islam
la france a là pas de problème avec
l'islam est la même une relation de
longue date nous sommes un des premiers
à avoir un des premiers pays à avoir
traduit le courant la sorbonne a été a
été le lieu de la foi de traduction de
commentaires de controverse
nous sommes un pays qui a toujours eu un
dialogue avec justement théologien de la
religion simplement nous avons construit
notre république notre projet collectif
dans la séparation entre le politique et
le religieux
c'est ça que parfois beaucoup de régions
du monde ont du mal à comprendre et
cette séparation c'est de dire que le
religieux ne doit pas venir faire de la
politique est une politique qui se dit
cependant de relier et je vais donc donc
mis là c'est un cas intolérable on a
fait le maximum pour la elle a été comme
vous le savez protéger elle est toujours
sous protection
mais elle est la victime de coin de gens
qui considèrent qu'en france on n'aurait
pas le droit de critiquer une religion
mais on peut critiquer toutes religions
et peut critiquer tous courants
philosophiques et on ne doit tolérer
aucune violence dont de cette critique
est justement j'en profite pour saluer
la communauté qui est très nombreuses à
nous regarder sur les différentes
plateformes de brut brut officiel et
cette question qui revient elle est
notée par karim c'est je suis français
j'ai mon pays et pourtant je ne suis pas
charlie est ce que j'ai le droit
je vous avez vous avez le droit si vous
êtes d'abord vous avez le droit français
jeu
je comprends très bien ce qu'il ya
derrière cette formule de là où je suis
et de là où je parle toujours dit moi je
suis en forme je suis la république on
l'a dit dans l'émotion de charlie est en
fait tout ce qu'ils ont dit je suis
charlie voulait dire quoi je suis la
république et je pense qu'à ce moment là
quand beaucoup de jeunes ont dit moi je
me suis mal à l'aise je ne me reconnais
pas dans charlie ils ont voulu dire
quelque chose qui me choque dans charlie
je ne suis pas à l'aise avec ce qu'ils
sont ce qu'ils font il faut comprendre
pourquoi ce phénomène et qu'on a vu au
centuple après
l'actos terroriste contre ça mais elle
pâtit et c'est ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et donc je pense qu'il faut
dépasser l'indignation qu'on peut avoir
lorsque il n'ya pas l'élan de solidarité
autour d'un mot d'ordre comme je le
disais moi je je sais quel est le prénom
de ce terrible donc c'est karim déjà
parce que décarie mais fort et dit je
suis français républicain
j'aime mon pays j'aime mon pays je ne
suis pas cher il se demande tout
simplement est ce que j'ai le droit
c'est ça non il a il faut qu'ils
expliquent qu est ce que ça veut dire
moi j'aime pas les slogans parce que ça
réduit tout qu'est ce que ça veut dire
je suis charlie je pense dans la forme
générique
ça veut dire j'adhère aux valeurs de la
république et en particulier à cette
liberté d'expression et moi je voudrais
convaincre karim que c'est une belle
idée
après il a le droit de ne pas aimer
charlie hebdo comme journal oui et moi
j'ai un devoir absolu qui est de les
défendre dans leur liberté
donc voilà je pense qu'il faut sortir du
slogan mais ce que je voudrais faire
comprendre à karim c'est que bien sûr il
a le droit de ne pas se retrouver dans
un slogan qui trouveraient trop
simpliste mais moi ce que j'attends de
lui c'est évidemment qu'il qui respecte
qui se retrouvent dans les lois de la
république et dans nos valeurs et et
qu'ils en soient fiers et qu'ils les
portent et qui comprennent peut-être que
dans certaines qui a dans ses valeurs et
l'expression de celle ci des choses qui
ont pu peut-être le choqué parce que
certains qui ont dit je suis pas sûr a
dit c'était ça qui était la provocation
à l'égard d'une religion quand on nous
quand on croit dans cette religion et je
pense qu'il faut comprendre que la
france s'est construite comme ça on a le
droit de critiquer une religion en
france quelques quelle qu'elle soit on a
beaucoup plus critiquée en france
la religion catholique on a critiqué
l'islam mais parce que on est protégé
dans un débat libre et que ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on ne respecte pas cette
religion et je pense c'est ça et c'est
une force incroyable dans un monde qui
est en train de se fracturer où il ya
d'un côté le politiquement correct où
les gens en fait ne veulent plus vivre
dans le même monde veut juste pas
choquer l'autre et de l'autre côté où il
ya un projet d'islam politique qui est
en train de gagner dans une partie du
monde et vous citiez le dirigeant turc
c'est son projet de cet islam politique
mais en france il tourne depuis tout à
l'heure de
juste rendre pas de recul pardon hein
mais depuis tout à l'heure on tourne
mais qui sont quand même le monde bien
derrière une même question c'est qu'est
ce que c'est qu'être français
aujourd'hui
mais c'est une question que je comprends
très bien dans la jeunesse c'est
justement c'est quoi exactement être
français aujourd'hui en 2020 c'est parti
d'abord c'est participer à un projet à
une citoyenneté
on n'est pas un pays où il ya le droit
du sang et être français c'est pas une
couleur et c'est pas une religion
premier point mais pas une plutôt que
l'autre c'est une histoire qui a été
nourrie par la religion catholique
l'apport du protestantisme ensuite
l'apport du judaïsme et plus récemment
la porte de l'islam et donc qui a connu
différentes religions mais qui s'est
construit comme un projet et être
français c'est d'abord être un citoyen
c'est-à-dire adhérer à des valeurs
liberté égalité fraternité laïcité
être français c'est ensuite habité une
langue et pour moi c'est extrêmement
important c'est habité une langue
parfois habités plusieurs langues mais
habité cette langue savoir la manier la
comprendre l'enrichir la transformer
parce que la france faut jamais
l'oublier elle s'est faite par deux
choses la langue et l'état très peu de
pays qui ont cette histoire des nations
comme la langue les ordonnances de
villers cotterêts françois 1er et l'état
qui progressivement à structurer les
lois un cadre etc
alors j ai donc demandé 15 secondes 15
139 ce que je sais ce que je veux dire
c'est que être français c'est du coup
adhérer à ces valeurs pleinement
c'est en même temps à est d'habiter
cette langue ces derniers sont les
commentaires et donc et donc c'est
appartenir à une histoire mais qui est
enrichi de toutes vos histoires et donc
c'est pas une histoire unique qui est
déjà écrite est figé et elle se nourrit
de toutes ces histoires venant de venant
de tous les continents parce que la
france est un pays monde en quelque
sorte on a une question de zac sur
twitch parce qu'on est aussi diffusée
sur tout et du brut officiel quelle est
la définition de la laïcité donc pour
vous la laïcité c'est la liberté de
croire comme de ne pas croire
une liberté la laïcité la laïcité ça
veut dire que je me fiche de savoir ce
que je disais tout à l'heure
sans citer la référence c'est que dans
nous en tant que citoyens nous pouvons
croire à une religion ou ne pas croire
ça veut dire que je n'ai pas même à
savoir ce que vous croyez
et je n'ai pas à rentrer dans votre
religion ça veut dire je ne vous demande
pas de croire d'une certaine manière ou
d'une autre mais ce que je vous demande
en tant que citoyen c'est de respecter
absolument toutes les lois de la
république et donc en même temps que au
nom d'une religion quelle qu'elle soit
vous ne pouvez pas dérogé à la
république
pourquoi parce que c'est ça être
français c'est cette citoyenneté et donc
contrairement à ce que disent beaucoup
la laïcité ce n'est pas un principe qui
serait contre une religion parce que
elle n'interdit pas la religion dans la
société il ya du religieux
il ya la religion par tout simplement
pour articuler la vie en société notre
vie justement spirituel notre vie social
le culturel civilisationnel familiale
avec la vie de citoyens qui est un
commun et qui nous dépasse on a besoin
de cette voie là de cette laïcité est un
point de passage et c'est et c'est très
important parce que c'est à la fois
montré qu'il ya d'appartenance et de
l'universel et là dessus je veux
vraiment le moi je crois beaucoup à ça
je crois pas une certain usage parfois
de la laïcité qui étaient contre le
religieux ou pour éradiquer le religieux
mais tout ce qu'on tousse conte depuis
tout à l'heure c'est le défi de de notre
génération sein de nos générations c'est
de réussir à vivre
retrouvez les raisons qui font qu'on
vive ensemble et qu'on fait l'histoire
justement paraître vivre ensemble est un
gros défi pour notre génération
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans en 2020 ce sont
vos mots et c'est vrai amour que d'être
jeune en 2020 c'est particulièrement
compliqué entendre que 20,19
le président moi je voulais vous
raconter l'anecdote j'étais à quelques
jours dans une fête l'an destine à paris
je me suis rendu pour un reportage et il
y avait énormément de monde aime des
centaines de personnes des étudiants
avant des tas de personnes qui étaient
là qui danse et qui devait dans les
mêmes vers le port du masque n'est pas
forcément respectée donc les gestes
mariage est complètement sauté et quand
on a discuté avec ces personnes on leur
a demandé mais est-ce que vous êtes
conscients des risques que vous prenez
et ces personnes disent eh oui on est
conscient mais on est seul on est isolé
c'est une question de survie pour nous
je vais pas vous dire que c'est génial
non mais d'abord d'abord je comprends
très bien
je comprends très bien enfin j'ai aussi
vécu cette période et même quand on est
un peu plus de 40 ans on a parfois aussi
envie de souffler et donc qui plus est
quand on est étudiant loin de sa famille
qu'on est venu étudier qu'on est dans
des conditions de vie modeste pour pas
dire précaire on a besoin de souffler de
retrouver ses formes je moi j'ai donc je
n'ai pas de leçon de morale à donner je
comprends ans est à la fois cette
solitude et cette souffrance morale qui
est là et parfois psychique qui est
forte et qui est identifié donc je le
coup je le comprends très bien
après j'aurai un message qu'il faut
essayer d'inventer et d'innover là aussi
est d'inventer d'autres formes pour se
sentir moins seul mais qui vous met
moins en danger
je pense que c'est possible pourquoi
parce que si vous êtes étudiante ou un
étudiant c'est pas forcément vous vous
mettez en danger
mais si vous faites cette fête de ce
qu'on sait de ce virus vous allez mettre
peut-être en danger votre père ou votre
grand-père votre grand-mère les jours
après quand vous le retrouver pour les
fêtes
justement ce qu'ils nous disaient sait
jamais si c'est que on sait qu'on est
isolé comprendre on prend des risques
mais on n'ira pas voir nos
grands-parents n'ira pas voir le parent
c'est moins vite c'est moins pire comme
comme on dit parfois mais mais donc
voilà donc mais en tout cas je pense
qu'il faut continuer c'est une période
de contraintes collectives inédite et
c'est une période
au fond on a décidé collectivement de
prendre soin les uns des autres et de
nous mettre des contraintes pour prendre
soin les uns des autres parce qu'on
n'avait rien de plus efficace
ce qui à la fois et très traumatisant
pour nous tous parce que c'est n'a
jamais vécu une telle way une telle
contrainte et ce qui est en même temps
je le dis pour pour la nation qui est la
nôtre comme toutes celles qui ont joué à
vivre ça c'est quand même une forme et
dames solidarité parce qu'on a su faire
un effort collectif pour protéger les
plus faibles
et ça c'est quand même voilà on l'a fait
et on est en train de le faire la
deuxième chose qui est vrai c'est que le
confinement en particulier parce qu'en
fait ce qui fait encore plus souffrir en
particulier quand on est jeune c'est le
confinement où les contraintes c'est
extraordinairement injustes
c'est à dire c'est beaucoup plus dur
quand on a des conditions modestes c'est
plus dur quand on est jeune en effet
parce qu'on a par définition une ville
qui est matériellement plus précaires on
est loin de ses proches
c'est plus dur parce qu'on a moins de
moyens et c'est un accélérateur d'une
égalité c'est en moins de moyens
ce mal être des jeunes j'ai vu aussi moi
même sur le terrain pour brut où j'ai vu
ces distributions alimentaires ces
derniers mois avec deux déjà de plus en
plus de monde mais aussi de plus en plus
de jeunes que j'ai pu interviewer qui me
disaient mais moi c'est la première fois
que j'avais une distribution alimentaire
les petits boulots se sont arrêtés pour
beaucoup oui il ya cette difficulté
aujourd'hui et ça ça se traduit par
énormément de questions dans les
commentaires
va-t-il y avoir d'autres z pour les
étudiants à quand un rsa pour les moins
de 25 ans qu'elle aide pour les
étudiants non boursiers
quelle réponse aujourd'hui on peut
donner peut-être supplémentaires à ceux
qui nous regardent si c'est alors
d'abord il ya eu il ya un conseil il ya
une plate forme qui a été créé un jeune
une solution qui est vraiment très bien
fait et très simple qui permet de voir
si vous cherchez une formation un emploi
une aide et qui vous permet qui permet
de vraiment de mettre en relation et
d'apporter des réponses très simple est
donc cette plateforme il faut l'utiliser
elle et elle est extrêmement est
extrêmement simple facile d'accès qui
apprennent vous branche
les bons canaux aujourd'hui c'est parce
que vous décrivez c'est une réalité
c'est vrai alors qu'est ce qu'on a comme
réponse on a mis en place ce plan un
jeune une solution il ya 1,6 milliard et
demi d'euros de montant qui paraissent
toujours abstrait parce que c'est en
milliards qu'est ce qu'on a mis derrière
un pour les jeunes qui sortent de la
formation accéder à l'emploi
on a fait une très grosse réforme de
l'apprentissage qui est en train de
produire ses fruits on atteint les 400
milles apprentis
on a décidé d'aider des entreprises et
les entrepreneurs enfin les employeurs
qu'ils étaient prêts à prendre un
apprenti en cette rentrée on paye
beaucoup avec une aide spéciale y jouent
le jeu donc continuer à demander
justement de l'apprentissage et l'accès
à l'emploi par l'apprentissage premier
point parce que c'est très dur par
apprentissage
parce qu'on est des quins d'encadrement
c'est très dur de trouver en effet des
nouveaux jobs
le deuxième sujet ensuite c'est ce qu'on
a fait sur les service civique qui
permet aussi pour semestre parfois une
année d'avoir justement une activité des
rémunérations en encadrement une
formation des choses qui sont
qualifiantes
on a plus que doublé les services
civiques là dessus il faut y aller
c'était vraiment des plateformes qui en
plus se réconcilient je dirais
l'engagement le sens et le besoin de
sens avec eux la possibilité d'avoir un
cadre et de de subvenir à ses besoins
troisième point on a aussi boosté
renforcée des dispositifs de garantie
jeunes de tout ce qui est justement les
plans d'insertion et compétences pour
les plus jeunes avec là aussi un très
gros investissement pour toutes celles
et ceux qui sont en sortie de formation
ça c'est pour tous les jeunes qui ont
fini leur formation est qui qui ne
trouvent pas d'emploi qui allait
s'ouvrir et qui rentre dans la vie
active dans une situation difficile
donc là je parle de centaines de
milliers de solutions qui sont proposées
ensuite quand vous êtes en étude donc on
a aussi adapté les choses permis à
beaucoup de jeunes de poursuivre leurs
études un semestre ou une année
supplémentaire en ouvrant des formations
additionnel est là comment comment
l'aide s'est mise en place
bon on a d'abord on s'est assurés avec
les crous qui est partout les restos u
qui soit ouvert avec le restaurant euros
je suis là on a développé quoi on a mis
fin à la sécu sociale étudiante qui
coûtait avant assez cher à l'année c'est
donc là on a mis à zéro mais je le dis
et puis il ya être au crous pour avoir
son repas 1 euro et donc quand on est
dans une formation universitaire faut y
aller demander au crous le repas un euro
il continue à être assurés dans cette
période
ensuite le vrai sujet qu'on a c'est
qu'on a on a déjà mis en place des aides
juste après une première phase vous en
avez déjà mis en place et ce que et donc
si ça continue on va en mettre en place
un premier trimestre encore le premier
ministre et ministre ont déjà dit qu'ils
sont des êtres exceptionnels avec
maintenant comme celle qu'on a fait pour
les jeunes qui sont aux apl 550 euros
alors exactement sont des aides
exceptionnelles mais qui l'a dépendent
qui permettent de couvrir quoi ce que le
job d'appoint permettait de couvrir
quand bien même on est boursier est donc
là on va travailler j'ai demandé qu'on
travaille sur deux choses pour le début
d'année prochaine
d'une part si ça continue la durée et en
fonction de ce que les universités et
les crous nous remonte
est-ce qu'on a besoin de refaire une
aide exceptionnelle d'autre part est ce
que et comment on peut améliorer notre
système de bourse
on a en france la chance d'avoir des
études gratuites on a en france un
système de bourses qui est efficace
qu'on a rendu plus efficace encore la
ministre l'a élargie mais il ya des
trous dans la raquette parce que moi
j'ai vu aussi en effet comme vous des
scènes où il ya des jeunes qui sont
obligés de parfois de faire le pire pour
pouvoir subvenir à leurs besoins qui
vont à l'aide alimentaire ça ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que manifestement
il ne touche pas l'argent qui font tant
que boursier pour pouvoir avoir le
minimum minimorum donc ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit adapter en début de
semaine questions très concrètes qui
nous est remonté voilà le panel
rapidement brossé des solutions dans des
nouvelles solutions des nouvelles
solutions jet tours jeu tel qu'il ya y
en aura encore sur janvier je pense que
celle ci est pourtant mais concrètement
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur celles qui
vont avec
ces améliorations du système de bourse
est sans doute encore une aide
exceptionnelle face à la précarité des
personnes qu'on a j'ai 750 euros qu'on a
fait à deux reprises d'en bas qui serait
a priori à lui qu'on a fait mais
peut-être qu'on a un truc plus
intelligente à faire
moi ce qui me frappe c'est ce que je
veux comprendre c'est alors qu'on a mis
en place tous ces systèmes
comment on allait scène que parfois vous
aller filmer ou les retours que vous
avez ça veut dire qu'il ya des qui a des
trous dans notre dispositif est donc
c'est plutôt ça qu'il faut améliorer
et justement cette question les
commentaires que nous tout simplement
c'est julia sur instagram ces derniers
jours qui nous dit à caen à rsa pour les
moins de 25 ans alors je ne suis pas un
grand fan de cette option pourquoi parce
que on a aujourd'hui la garantie jeunes
qui suppose une démarche d'insertion
on a les bourses quand vous faites des
études et vous êtes précaire on a le
parcours emploi compétences et moi je
pense que dans notre société le grand
défi qu'on a c'est un rapport au travail
et on a lutté contre la pauvreté avec
les minima sociaux et c'est un acquis
ils sont très importants
j'ai assumé j'ai décidé et relever
certains minima sociaux de manière
historique
l'allocation adulte handicapé comme le
minimum vieillesse de 100 euros
chacun 200 euros mais la difficulté
qu'on a et ça on le sait c'est tout à
fait vrai dans des pays en voie de
développement que un revenu minimal
permet de donner de la sécurité rentrait
dans l'emploi dans des pays comme les
nôtres
les économistes ont montré si l'écart
entre la non activité l'activité n'est
pas suffisant vous créer des systèmes de
désincitation au tour dans l'emploi je
sais que ça fait pas ça fait pas plaisir
je me fais toujours attaquée par plein
de monde quand je dis ça mais c'est
assez vrai assez vérifier tant et si
vrai que d'ailleurs au moment de la
crise des gilet jaune
beaucoup de gens disaient nous on
travaille mais on n'a pas d'intérêt à
travailler on paye pour les autres et
qu'est-ce que j'ai décidé en sortie de
crise et gilet jaune et je l'assumé
totalement
une augmentation historique de la prime
d'activité qui va aux travailleurs les
plus modestes ceux qui sont au smic 200
euros à chaque fois que j'augmente le
rsa je suis obligée d'augmenter le
montant
aidé par la collectivité au salaire
minimum parce que je ne peux pas
demander aux entreprises de l'augmenter
si je le fais je tue ma compétitivité je
détruis de l'emploi donc c'est un
circuit sans fin donc moi je préfère
qu'on fasse quoi de la lutte contre la
pauvreté par l'insertion à l'activité
économique par le travail avec les
associations de terrain par de
l'accompagnement économique mais aussi
de l'accompagnement humain pour celles
et ceux qui sont le plus loin de
l'emploi par des initiatives comme
territoire 06 chômeurs auxquels je crois
à fond et qu'on est en train de
généraliser et qui est un formidable
travail daté dé carbon et après du
député grandguillaume et puis de
beaucoup de parlementaires et d'acteurs
de terrain et je crois pour les jeunes à
la garantie jeune je le dis d'autant
plus facilement que c'est pas moi qui
les ai inventées on a beaucoup
multiplier mais pour les jeunes je crois
à quoi garantie jeunes service civique
les plans emploi compétences c'est à
dire des choses où il ya dès le début un
contrat de responsabilité alors et vous
dire études contre red où il ya enfin
oui parce que c'est comme ça que ça
marche
alors il ya aussi autre chose qui est
très important pour les étudiants il ya
énormément de questions qui remonte
peut-être parce que c'est un moyen aussi
de se retrouver et de retrouver une vie
psychique convenable thibault par
exemple sur facebook nous écrit monsieur
le président vous écrit monsieur le
président pourquoi réouvrir les
universités bien après le reste je
rappellerai que vous avez décidé que les
ouvrez les universités rouvriraient
début février
revenu débilité au mieux à leurs
milliers de fois qu'on a vu ça je
comprends tout à fait et je alors je
rappelle qu'il ya six mois on reprocher
plutôt d'ouvrir trop vite les écoles
c'est vrai donc moi j'assume qu'on ait
fait un choix en france d'ouvrir à
chaque fois le plus tôt possible les
lieux où on apprend et on l'a fait
surtout pour les plus jeunes parce que
ça crée des inégalités d'apprentissage
des inégalités sociales très fortes
donc on l'a fait pour crèches écoles
collèges j après plus on est grand plus
l'organisation peut se faire un peu
différemment et on peut faire on peut
mieux apprendre en ont présentiel s'est
jamais idéal je vous rejoins tout à fait
mais c'est aussi pour ça que prénom
police est là dans la période la plus
dure on a fait des deux je dis honte
parce que je vous aime c'est une
proposition des professeurs mais dès
2000 classe pour éviter qu est
heureusement et donc beaucoup de lycéens
ont eu la moitié de leurs cours et c'est
vrai que les universités qui sont en
même temps des lieux de très grande
circulation où il ya des lieux aussi de
vie commune qui était donc des lieux
très qui ont été un moment sans doute
très contagieux malgré vraiment le
travail formidable qu'on fait à la fois
les étudiants tous ceux qui sont
responsables de la vie étudiante les
profs et les présidents d'université
on les a fermés au pic là on s'est dit
d'abord on peut un peu plus longtemps
que les autres tenir en en présentiel
je leur dit la ministre et la ministre
donc en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation du premier ministre ont
commencé nous commencions c'était
aujourd'hui les concertations avec
justement les présidents d'université et
d'enseignants on va essayer je touche du
bois
si ça me si nos résultats sont là de
commencer plus tôt et sans doute qu'on
va essayer de reprendre davantage de t&d
en présentiel reprendre peut-être si les
chiffres sont bons début janvier des
cours mais en demies en fille et au fond
c'est un peu toujours pareil faut
s'adapter au terrain
quand vous avez des élèves qui sont dans
un film de sens et qui sont 50
on peut sans doute reprendre le cours en
présentiel en présentiel beaucoup plus
tôt quand vous ans quand vous êtes dans
des formations ou pour des amphis 300 il
ya 350 élèves c'est moi c'est moins une
bonne idée bon et après il faut des
protocoles très stricts pour les lieux
un peu de vie comme une cafétéria est
haute pour éviter qu'ils aient trop de
brassage donc voilà la stratégie donc je
veux vous rassurer
1 d'abord chaque étape elle et elle
dépend de ce qu'on a su consolider donc
à une étape au la 15 décembre l'autre et
au 20 janvier
et on va tout faire pour pouvoir
commencer un peu plus tôt en janvier
pour rouvrir td et demi en finale je
rappelle pour toutes les personnes qui
nous regardent actuellement notamment
sur facebook lite parce que je vois
qu'elle est dizaines de milliers de
commentaires
on continue d'accumuler vos questions et
on gardera un petit temps avec vous
monsieur le président pour pouvoir vous
les voulez poser la fin de ce direct
mais pour continuer justement par
rapport aux copies de 19
on parle de ces jeunes enfermés de cette
génération qui se dit sacrifier vous
avez annoncé qu'un vaccin arrivera très
prochainement
si c'est la solution pourquoi il n'est
pas obligatoire alors d'abord moi je
serais très prudent sur le sujet suis
pas scientifique médecin
il ya des vaccins qui arrive n'a pas
qu'un là on a un vaccin qui est en train
d'arriver sur la rn message et c'est une
première mondiale sur aucun virus on
avait eu cette technologie est donc un
il faut que ce soit autorisée par les
autorités sanitaires en particulier
européennes ensuite on a une stratégie
qui est donnée par la haute autorité de
santé et puis on va le faire en
commençant par les les personnes les
plus âgées en ehpad
et puis des personnes qui travaillent
dans les ehpad et qui ont des facteurs
de fragilité est prêt à faire pour les
personnes qui sont âgés en ville voilà
progressivement
et puis après tout la population je
crois pas à la vaccination obligatoire
pour ce vaccin parce que d'abord il faut
être toujours très honnêtes et
transparents on ne sait pas tout sur ce
vaccin comme on ne sait pas tout sur le
virus à chaque étape on dira tout ce
qu'on sait sur l'efficacité
là on a des premiers chiffres qui
viennent des autorités de santé et des
labos mais donc on doit savoir à chaque
fois il ya un bilan coût avantages de la
vaccination et après je crois beaucoup
plus au travail de conviction par la
transparence cal l'obligation sur des
accents auquel on était très habitué
pour les enfants qu'on fait depuis des
décennies on a décidé la vaccination
obligatoire en début de mandat ça a été
un très gros débat démocratique dans
notre pays est en paix avec des vaccins
qu'on connaissait par coeur on avait des
décennies de recul je pense que c'est
contreproductif de rendre le vaccin
obligatoire sur des vaccins qu'on
connaît mal sur une pathologie souvent
quand audi on ne connaît pas tous sur
les vaccins seraient peut être aussi
quelque part je veux dire en tant que
citoyen si on me disent ah bah c'est
aussi inquiétant que quelque part je
veux qu'on a tous les éléments
aujourd'hui pour assurer londres se dire
bon il n'ya pas donc on les abat donc on
a les autorités sanitaires considèrent
qu est-ce que quel que font les
autorités de santé quand elle autorise
avec ça ou un médicament
elle regarde deux choses elle regarde
l'efficacité et la toxicité
parce qu'il faut jamais oublier qu'un
médicament comme ailleurs c'est
l'origine du terme pharmakon en grec
c'est à la fois le médicament il présent
tout médicament c6 est mal utilisé sa
des effets secondaires ça peut être
mauvais et donc elles font le bilan
et elle regarde est-ce que c'est
efficace et au delà de quel point les
autorités américaines elles se sont bien
seuil de 50%
et est-ce que c'est toxique et qu'est-ce
qu'on a identifié mais il vient
d'arriver donc là elles disent pour nous
ces médicaments le kaiser bio une taille
puisqu'il a été autorisé aux états unis
ils disent il est plus de 50 % des cas
et donc plus de 50% des cas efficace et
là une toxicité qui ne pose pas de
questions ils vont je pense dire quels
sont les risques et pour qui moi j'ai
pas toutes les informations au moment où
je vous parle
et donc c'est ça ce qu'on va faire à
chaque fois ce que vous voyez en france
il ya souvent cette question par rapport
au vaccin vous l'évoquez également les
instants d'une certaine forme de
défiance qui est très important mais
puisque je pense contré par le blick et
les personnes qui disent le vaccin ce
sera sans moi qu'est ce que vous leur
dites aujourd'hui jeudi
d'abord n'est pas un propos définitifs
ce sera des vaccins le vaccin d'avril ne
sera pas celui de janvier il ya des
vaccins qui vont arriver au printemps
été qui sont faits avec d'autres
techniques
nous aussi on nous dit ça vaut mieux
attendre avril pour d'abord je vais vous
rassurer je vous rassure et décembre
janvier février ce sera pas une liberté
encore je ne pourrai pas aller sonner ou
appeler une adresse pour avoir le vaccin
on va être obligé compte tenu de la
faible dose et des priorités d'aller sur
des cibles privilégiées et de d'aller
d'abord vacciner celles et ceux pour qui
il ya un intérêt celles et ceux pour qui
c'est le plus sensible vous ne pourrez
pas prendre si vous en janvier vous
dites je me faire vacciner que vous y
alliez on vous dira non
donc c'est à un moment donné qu'on va
ouvrir à la vaccination pour toute la
population et ce à un moment donné ça a
été précisé hier par le premier ministre
ministre est professeur fisher ça va
arriver dans une phase
je dirais après la première phase soit
déjà organiser la vaccination des
personnes qui ont le plus de risques de
développer les formes graves et qui le
font plus de mortels est ce que c'est le
vaccin qui va nous permettre de sortir
de tout ce qu'on vit actuellement il ya
cette question qui est revenue beaucoup
dans les commentaires de se dire mais
ces restrictions le sont durs porter un
masque aux traits des bars les
restaurants
c'est très dur les enfants c'est très
angoissant pour eux et moi je vois aussi
suivre les conséquences le plein la
question c'est jusqu'à temps et c'est
très dur pour les gens qui sont dans
l'angoissé aussi sur le lancement aux
restaurateurs aux commerçants à qui on a
demandé beaucoup d'efforts que les
restaurateurs qui disent aussi j'attends
le 20 janvier aux étudiants donc oui
c'est très dur simplement à quel moment
peut envisager une sortie aujourd'hui de
ce qui se passe parce que ces virus nous
à nous apprend deux choses d'abord notre
vulnérabilité
moi je pense que la génération la
génération 20 en 2020
plus que tout autre elle est là elle
c'est le besoin de sens et sa
vulnérabilité
parce qu'elle a vécu le terrorisme du
changement climatique et la devient un
virus et ce virus nous a montré un truc
quelque chose qui se passe en chine peut
toucher nos vies on est vulnérable
bon eh bien non c'est pas ça reste un
vaccin sûr présents si vous avez vu mais
les anciens présidents américains barack
obama george bush et bill clinton ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient se faire
vacciner devant les caméras est ce que
vous seriez prêt à vous faire vacciner
aussi devant les caméras je convaincre
je le ferai au moment où ça a du sens et
ça correspond à notre stratégie mais
mais moi je vais pas du tout faire moi
linverse de ce que je recommande pour la
population on n'a pas la même stratégie
de vaccination que est donc aujourd'hui
ce que je vous disais on n'est pas en
train de dire aux gens vaccinez vous
vacciner vous à toute force et pour
toute la population on a une autre à tj
face à ce virus on ne connaissait pas on
a vu que c'était un virus qui était
mortel surtout pour les plus âgés mais
touché en forme grave parfois à tous les
âges
on est en train d'essayer de comprendre
d'où ça vient ce matin j'étais
formidable à l'institut imagine ils sont
en train de voir que peut-être il ya des
explications génétique
donc on va commence bien on va à marche
forcée la france est dans l'excellence
scientifique sur ce sujet mais quand on
a ça et que le virus commence à se
répartir partout
la seule réponse c'est celle qu'on avait
face à la peste au moyen âge c'est en
effet l' isolement complet et donc on a
fermé les rues comme on faisait au moyen
âge c'est le truc le plus absurde de
leurs photos au moyen âge par forme
était déjà dans une maison et on
attendait tout le monde meurt pour la
rouvrir
on va éviter ça non mais bien faire mais
je dis ça parce que l'organisation
collective heures c'est beaucoup plus
sophistiqué mais c'est exactement ce
qu'on a fait c'est à dire que comme on
en savait si peu et qu'à un moment donné
on a fait un choix humaniste collectif
de protéger des vies venir le choix que
nous avons tous ceux que nous avons tous
fait nous société dont on dit parfois on
et consumériste l'économie mennetou on a
fait un choix et humaniste on a dit on
est prêt à arrêter l'économie la
consommation etc pour protéger des vies
faut jamais l'oublier
et ça on la fait tous ensemble et
honnêtement on est un pays où et de la
controverse et du débat en permanence
doute les françaises et les français ils
ont tenu les deux qu'on fait après la
deuxième boîte et j attends de venir
parce qu allez-vous rhétorique et pour
moi il ya un deuxième pilier qui est le
tester alerté protégé qui est la
deuxième réponse qu'on a fait face aux
grandes épidémies en sortie du moyen-âge
quand on a su mieux comprendre comment
les chaînes de contamination se faisait
on a plus isolé toute la population on a
mis à l'écart les gens qui étaient
contaminés c'est ce qu'on faisait avec
les léproseries par exemple m'étais
juste à part les gens qui avaient la
terrible maladie
c'est pas du tout là aussi je vous
rassure ce qu'on propose mais c'est le
même raisonnement c'est de dire on veut
tester au maximum beaucoup plus vite
pourtant c'est ce qu'on va faire à
partir de janvier cent pour cent des
tests dans les 24 heures alertée c'est à
dire grâce à l'appli tout senti qu vide
qui est très importante on remonte les
chaînes grâce aux appels qu'on fait de
l'assurance maladie
et puis on va faire on va inciter les
gens à s'isoler
pendant ces sept jours en les
accompagnant économiquement en les
accompagnant avec des gens qui vont les
appeler qui vont aider s'il ya des
problèmes en responsabilisant en
essayant de mettre aussi un peu plus de
de contrôle individuel parce que c'est
ça qui permettra de casser la chaîne de
contamination est d'éviter que voilà ça
s'embrase et donc la clé de la stratégie
à partir du moment où on va complètement
sortir du confinement
ça va être le tester alerte et protégé
est vraiment protéger tout
particulièrement les plus âgés les plus
fragiles en même temps continuer à
recherche et c'est de continuer à
améliorer les traitements pour éviter
les formes graves ou pour les formes
graves de mourir et là on s'est beaucoup
amélioré et progressivement de vacciner
mais le vaccin n'est en fait la solution
que le jour où vous avez entre 50 et 60
% de votre population qu est ce qu on
appelle l'immunité collective c'est à
dire qu'il fait que où elle a les
anticorps parce qu'elle l'a eue où elle
a été vaccinée en cours et il faudra
plusieurs mois avant que ce soit le
vaccin
moi je pense que notre organisation
collective plus stratégie de vaccination
plus la recherche sur le traitement
et la compréhension c'est vrai c'est un
peu c'est le mix de cette stratégie
alors votre stratégie elle a besoin
jusqu'au printemps prochain que l'on va
devoir encore être vives entre un temps
été votre stratégie de votre stratégie
repose largement sur la confiance des
citoyens
c'est normal oui on a été parfois
contraignant on a reproché et je le sais
ouais et puis une forme de défiance
cette défiance est ce que vous dites pas
aussi qu'elle a un peu de votre faute
vous emmanuel macron vous peut-être
aussi le pouvoir plus largement les
masques fallait pas en porter et puis il
fallait remporter les tests c'était
quand même plus que laborieux au début
est ce que vous vous dites parfois que
finalement on est à un moment où il est
plus difficile peut-être de demander aux
citoyens leur confiance quand on leur a
pas montré qu'on pouvait être dit est-ce
que tout a été bien fait j'ai dit non
est-ce qu' il ya un pays qui a tout bien
fait je ne les ai pas vus nous sommes un
pays où d'abord on est à nous français
nous sommes plus défiants que beaucoup
d'autres c'est ça a été montré depuis
des décennies par les les sociologues et
philosophes les ceux qui sont
spécialistes de sciences cognitives
c'est une réalité ce qui était plutôt un
handicap dans ces moments là et donc le
problème des masques tous les pays ont
eu les états unis d'amérique l'onu
l'allemagne l'a eu mais nous sommes un
pays où on attend c'est vrai tout de
l'état beaucoup de choses de l'état et
sur les masques je pense que on a eu des
ratés
je l' ai déjà dit on a eu des ratés dans
la dans la sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement
la plupart des pays ont eu ce raté là
parce qu en fait personne n'avait
anticipé qu'il puisse y avoir une rareté
sur les masques sur le marché
international à ce moment ça n'avait
quasiment plus de valeur parce que ça
circuler partout
c'est ce qui d'ailleurs nous a fait
toucher du doigt le besoin de
souveraineté c'est-à-dire de reproduire
en europe et en france
des choses simples qu'on avait laissé
être produit à l'autre bout du monde et
donc ça on a réappris la souveraineté et
c'est ce que diront décline des
conséquences très direct dans notre
stratégie industrielle française et
européenne ensuite là où il faut faire
très attention dans ces moments c'est
aussi pour ça que j'ai cette prudence
sur le vaccin c'est qu'il faut laisser
beaucoup plus parler les scientifiques
sur les masques c'est l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui a dit blé
dyneema sont pas une réponse
et puis qui d'un seul coup a dit
apprenant les choses beaucoup mieux si
ça peut être un instrument
et quand vous avez en effet martelé avec
un système où sa part le toute la
journée
lana ce que vous dites le contraire de
ce que vous avez dit pas ce que vous
avez appris progressivement et après on
a eu des ratés sur la chaîne logistique
donc oui tout ça installe un moment
donné des doutes simplement faux les
expliquer je pense qu'il faut toujours
savoir dire où est ce qu'on fait des
erreurs tout le monde peut faire tout le
monde peut faire des erreurs on en fait
tous tout le temps personne
l'infaillibilité ça n'existe pas et donc
il faut pouvoir à chaque fois dire
qu'est ce qu'on a raté l'expliqué en
transparence
le corriger et l'améliorer et c'est je
crois ce qu'on a essayé de faire
on a amélioré la chaîne logistique sur
la deuxième phase de tous les choses on
a amélioré notre organisation
grâce à nos soignants à l'hôpital comme
en ville on a beaucoup mieux prise en
charge cette deuxième phase que la
première et on s'est améliorés
collectivement mais je pense que il ya
ce n'est toujours une responsabilité de
cette et ceux qu'ils gouvernent mais je
pense que il faut aussi qu'on change un
peu collectivement notre mentalité c'est
à dire il faut être intraitable sur la
transparence ce que vous faites il faut
continuer à faire mais il faut qu'on
soit moins défier entre nous parce que
quelque sorte comme on est une société
qui est quand même très transparente
transparence plus défiance ça fait
effondrement mental un moment donné
c'est le scepticisme on n'a plus
confiance en clair que ce soit et donc
faut réussir à garder notre transparence
et notre exigence mais un moment les
dirigeants d'hier là on s'est trompé
qu'on corrige expliqué rendre compte et
du coup rebâtir de la confiance
collective quand on a corrigé les
comportements je crois que c'est comme
ça qu'on doit faire et se dire qu'on a
tous une part de la solution
on a tous une part de la solution alors
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent et des
dizaines de milliers de commentaires
pour tout vous dire ça part un peu dans
tous les sens notamment sur le facebook
live et je compte même pas les autres
plateformes où on est actuellement on
dirait que bien évidemment je compte sur
ce qu'ils sont en train de regarder ce
direct sur l'ensemble des plateformes de
brut brut officielle facebook twitter
instagram sur twitch également vous
continuez à poser vos questions dont on
continue de les faire remonter on en a
pas mal mais on a un sujet aussi qui
tient très à coeur à notre communauté
c'est celui de l'écologie l'écologie on
commence par cette question qui a été
posée sur instagram questions très
directes de berry berry qui veut vous
fait qu'il veut quelque part vous mettre
face à certaines contradictions salut
neeson le glyphosate
ouais cet herbicide que vous et que vous
vous étiez engagé à interdire à la fin
de l'année et berry nous dit tout
simplement je cite monsieur macron avait
promis l'interdiction du glyphosate au
plus tard en 2020 il a changé d'avis et
ce bien avant la pandémie comment faire
confiance à quelqu'un qui ne tient pas
ce pourquoi il a été élu
ah non je n'ai pas changé d'avis j'ai
pas réussi n'aurait pas réussi j'ai pas
changé d'avis je suis pour qu'on en
sorte
mais j'ai pas réussi c'est un échec
collectif
mais on va refaire le film depuis le
début sur ce qu'on n'a pas réussi le
glyphosate pour cela pour tout le monde
c'est en gros le roundup 20 c'est pas le
pire c'est pas le plus dangereux de très
loin parmi les herbicides et fongicides
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
dangereux je le dis mais c'est le plus
répandu et le plus utilisé de très loin
aussi
et la france est l'un des premiers
utilisateurs pourquoi parce que la
france est un grand pays agricole mais
on n'utilise pas dire que dans
l'agriculture on utilise aussi dans les
jardins publics
on l'utilisé dans le jardin public on en
sortait on l'utilisait pour entretenir
les rails de la sncf on va en sortir là
en 2021 novembre 2017 débat européen
parce que ça se gère au niveau européen
toutes ces choses là puisqu'on est un
marché unique l'europe agricole l'europe
contre les pesticides 7 c'est l'europe
c'est pas que la france
il ya un débat beaucoup de pays disent
on remet ça à 10 ans 15 ans on nous on
se bat non on dit en 2017
on veut que l'europe est un objectif à
trois ans l'europe mais son objectif à 5
en 2022
si la france si nous nous étions pas
battu à l'époque avec nicolas hulot pour
que au niveau européen on est une
majorité pour interdire le glyphosate en
europe 22 et avoir cette échéance en
tout cas ce point de rendez vous mais
les autres repartent et à 10 15 en tout
cas il y avait une majorité contre nous
et on a su comment c'était au début
battu sur trois ans j'ai dit ban aux
français je veux qu'on arrive en 3 ans à
le faire pourquoi on n'a pas réussi
obligé de le constater plusieurs choses
hein parce que quand les autres ne vont
pas au même rythme que nous sacré de la
distorsion de concurrence et en gros ça
fait que on sacrifie notre agriculture
pour régler le problème et on règle pas
vraiment le problème parce qu'on va
continuer à manger les mêmes aliments
qui était produit par nos agriculteurs
en le faisant à portée de belgique
d'italie ou d'espagne que continue avec
le glyphosate et donc ça montre une
chose quand on met quand on veut lutter
contre les pesticides c'est l'europe le
bon niveau c'est exactement m
même qu'on a vu sur les néonicotinoïdes
néonicotinoïdes en 2016 on dit on sort
totalement simplement tous les autres
pays européens mettent des exceptions
nous on n'en met pas boom sur la
betterave ça faisait partie des
exceptions les allemands les belges et
d'autres ont cette exception on l'a pas
on aurait simplement rien réglé du
problème on aurait réimporter du sucre
de ces pays tuez nos betteraviers sans
régler le problème de fond donc pourquoi
on n'a pas réussi sur le glyphosate
parce qu'en fait on peut pas gagner la
bataille tout seul si on n'a pas des
autres européens passent concret sinon
des distorsions de concurrence des
centres de faire un formidable plaidoyer
contre l'europe norske voix parce que at
il annoncé internautes permanent lorsque
pourquoi dans ce cas là ne pas interdire
chez nous remettent des barrières de
frontières autour de chez nous pour que
les produits qu'on apporte soit plus
cher et donc que nos produits sans
glyphosate soient compétitifs parce que
d'abord vous ne produisez pas toujours
même ce serait faux de le dire la france
est un grand pays producteur mais qui
exporte aussi beaucoup et vous mangez
beaucoup de choses qui sont produits
chez vos voisins et donc vous
continuerez à manger des choses qui sont
produites avec du glyphosate
donc ça ne règle pas le problème ensuite
parce que le marché unique est quelque
chose qui apporte beaucoup y compris à
vos agriculteurs en termes de revenus et
en termes d'accès à d'autres marchés
notre agriculture elle a été pensée à
l'échelle européenne et donc je pense
que je pense je suis sûr que hrw rag
menthe et au niveau national serait
mauvais pour nous et pour notre doute
autonomie alimentaire et ne permettrait
pas de régler le problème
je pense qu'au contraire quand on est si
voisins on a besoin d'avoir la même
stratégie simplement l'europe
et bien c'est un compromis permanent
parfois on voudrait aller plus vite sur
le numérique sur l'écologie et on doit
ramener des autres donc ce que je dis
c'est que le volontarisme français a
permis de faire ces cinq ans on a déjà
nous était plus vite que d'autres et on
est ce avec les luxembourgeois qui vont
le plus vite c'est beaucoup plus dur
pendant que pour nous qui luxembourgeois
parce que ils ont une ferme qui est
moins grande si je puis dire mais on
doit réussir ce chemin donc on n'a pas
réussi
mais je n'ai pas changé d'avis parce que
les autres sont restés un rythme plus
lent deuxième point parce que il y à des
filières qu'ils ont et qui ont souffert
d'autres phénomènes qu'on n'avait pas
prévu les taxes américaines par exemple
la viticulture la filière vitivinicole
elle était en train de sortir du
glyphosate plus vite ils ont eu un
problème c'est que ils ont eu les taxes
américaines
ils ont perdu beaucoup en rentabilité
ils ont dû ralentir
et la troisième chose c'est qu'il faut
apporter à chaque fois une solution à
l'agriculteur et pour moi c'est très
important parce que il ya des jeunes
agriculteurs qui s'installent ils ont
autant envie que vous de se débarrasser
des pesticides et fongicides
ils travaillent 75 à 80 heures par
semaine faux c'est ça leur vie ils ont
un revenu qui est parfois en dessous du
revenu minimum et si je leur interdis le
glyphosate sans solution la soie je leur
dis tu vas aller débroussailler à la
main ou à la machine
c'est des dizaines d'heures de plus par
semaine en plus c'est un investissement
je vais pas compensés et parfois c'est
impossible
simplement parce que il n'y a pas de
vraie substitut est donc là ce qu'on va
réussir à faire d'ici à fin 2022 nous
français déjà c'est qu'on aura baissé de
50%
comment on fait bah on n'a ni été à
marche forcée on a interdit d
autorisation de mise sur le marché de
certains usages du glyphosate
on a engagé des filières je veux saluer
tous les agriculteurs qui se sont
engagés avec nous et derrière on va les
accompagner par un crédit d'impôt pour
les aider à investir dans cette
transition pour sortir du glyphosate et
c'est hyper important et en même temps
j'insiste là dessus
qu'est ce qu'on fait on a remis de
l'argent et ce à son de le faire au
niveau européen pour trouver d'autres
solutions parce que si j'ai un
agriculteur qui n'utilisent plus lui
faisais tu mets qui utilise un herbicide
plus dangereux j'ai tout perdu
et donc c'est par la recherche d'autres
et d'autres intrants beaucoup moins
toxiques
c'est par la recherche d'autres
techniques c'est par là l'innovation
aussi par exemple quand je crée ce qu'on
appelle des cépages résilient pour la
vigne j'ai plus besoin d'eux mêmes de
production et notre question qui vient
dans les commentaires d'arthur pourquoi
le gouvernement revient-il sur les
principes de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat alors qu'il avait promis
de les appliquer alors il revient pas du
tout sur les principes d'abord rien
la convention citoyenne c'est une
expérience démocratique inédite
les irlandais avaient fait ça sur un
sujet sociétal question unique avant
d'entrer pour préparer un référendum
mais dire on prend tout un champ de
politique si compliqué de transition de
tension et on le confie à des citoyens
pour nous aider à aller plus loin plus
fort on ne l'avait jamais fait ailleurs
moi je veux saluer les 150 citoyens qui
ont fait un travail extraordinaire ce
sont des femmes et des hommes qui ont
pris sur leur temps qu'ils se sont
d'abord former pour ensuite proposer
mais c'est encore pire parce que
vous n'avez pas suivi l'or lors des
attendez attendez totalement je suis pas
d'accord avec cette approche s'est pas
encore pire 1 d'abord on les a respectés
on leur a donné les moyens de faire on
les a con non mais attendez c'est trop
facile de gagner à de le dire c'est
attendait s'il ya un truc qui nous plaît
pas non il n'avait pas fait non mais
faut arrêter ce soutien est donc une
expérience démocratique
je me suis engagé comme président de je
suis allé les voir 3g réceptionné les
travaux
j'ai dit les trois mesures que je
retenais pas et toutes les autres qu'on
avait passé quatre ya jamais eu dans
aucun pays au monde un gouvernement des
parlementaires qui se sont autant engagé
avec des citoyens et beaucoup de gens
m'ont dit que ce que vous allez avec des
citoyens là nous embêter ce qu'ils font
est loin ce sont les parlementaires ils
ont un mandat du peuple pour le faire
moi j'ai reconnu le fait qu' il n'avait
pas d'autre mandat que celui qui leur
est donné et on est en train de
travailler d'arrache-pied pour aller au
bout
simplement sur chacun de ces sujets
c'est pas des sujets où on peut dire
c'est à prendre ou à laisser ces faux et
donc le sans filtre c'est quoi c'est de
dire sur toutes vos propositions on y
avait on y va avec vous on construit un
texte de loi qu'on est tous prêts à
assumer et on va pas évacuer des
questions faciles mais c'est normal
qu'ils aient un travail qu'ils soient
encore en train de se fiancer les actes
qui sont attendus mais c'est il ya une
loi qui est attendu d'abord il ya des
mesures qui ont commencé à être prises
mais c'est une loi qui a tendu mais par
exemple il propose des mesures très
fortes sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments
j'y crois à fond on a commencé à
appliquer ce qu'ils proposent dans le
plan de relance en mettant des milliards
pour faire que les bâtiments qu'on
appelle les passoires thermiques qui
sont placés f ou g remonte mais est ce
que en conscience on va aller au bout du
bout qui à un moment de dire on met une
pénalité très forte ou l'interdiction de
vendre où on met le curseur
j'ai besoin que le travail soit terminé
entre les ministres et eux mais ça peut
pas être juste de dire une une qui a été
dit par les citoyens parce que derrière
qu'est ce que c'est ça veut dire que
vous vous n'avez pas forcément les
moyens vous avez une passoire thermique
et j'ai un moment vous mettre une
contrainte et un interdit donc il faut
en même temps on pense l'accompagnement
et la chose ils n'ont pas et ce qui est
normal tout prévu tous pensé il ya un
moment un travail de préparation comme
pour tout texte de loi qui est une étude
d'impact de regarder les conséquences
des mesures d'accompagnement via c'est
ça qu'on est en train de faire une
entrée bien je suis vraiment très en
colère contre des activistes qui m'ont
aidé au début qui disent maintenant
faudrait tous les mois on s'est
lourdement en banque
on sait tous ce qui s'énonce à cyril
durand et ouais mais c'est pas
non mais je le dis très sincèrement
parce que aussi vrais que des gens qui
sont parlementaires qui ont été élus
pour ça qu'il ya un mandat du peuple je
fais pas demain dire vous devez prendre
leurs textes comme si c'était vérité
révélée vous quand vous avez un problème
avec arctic 24 vous allez dans la rue ce
sont des parlementaires ils font leur
job ils ont une légitimité démocratique
vous avez le droit d'aller dans la rue
de dire ils font un truc qui me plaît
pas il le corrige j'ai 150 citoyens je
les respecte comme des parlementaires
mais je vais pas dire parce que ces 150
citoyens ont écrit un truc c'est la
bible ou le coran que sèche dans la
période si tendue qu'on connaît je
préfère pas prendre eux mêmes ces
comparaisons mais on n'aurait pas le
droit à un moment donné de continuer la
réflexion collective et de dire il ya
peut-être un ou deux endroits où il ya
des choses qui ne correspondent pas au
problème est qu'on peut en respect
mutuel continuer à travailler en
sciences pour ça ça c'est la solution
des fainéants alors tire sur les gens
qui disent là j'ai un truc c'est à
prendre ou à laisser
vous prenez pas c'est nul allez vous
n'avez pas fait le boulot
personne n'a autant fait que nous depuis
trois ans personne et je les assume
devant vous moi j'ai pas pris des lois
pour dans dix ans j'ai pas fais des
trucs pour les générations à venir
on est en train de fermer toutes les
centrales à charbon aucun autre pays au
monde l'a fait toutes les centrales à
charbon
celle qui vaut à 5 millions de véhicules
diesel con con con converti en véhicules
de nouvelle génération
on a converti vite 100000 véhicules qui
étaient en vieux diesel très polluant en
nouvelle génération en électrique ou
hybride et on continue l'investissement
on a arrêté des projets que tout le
monde
laisser traîner ne voulais pas arrêter
notre dame des landes la montagne d'or
europa city qui l'a arrêté qui l'a
arrêté
donc moi je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir
de tous les gens qui commencent à me
dire je dis simplement on a nos citoyens
qu'ils sont là ils ont fait un boulot
extraordinaire ce boulot je le respecte
j'irai au bout avec eux je vais les voir
mais qu' un citoyen qui est qui m'a aidé
à avoir cette idée
cyril dont est franchement que je
respecte ne fasse pas de caricature en
disant c'est à prendre ou à laisser vous
devez appliquer telle quelle il ya un
gouvernement qui a une responsabilité
démocratique il ya un parlement qui est
là c'est normal qu'il y à un moment un
travail avec ses citoyens pour finaliser
la solution c'est là où on en est et on
va le faire avec un texte de loi qui va
arriver en début d'année prochaine pour
pouvoir être votée et des actes et du
côté des citoyens on a par exemple une
question les commentaires qui dit
tout simplement j'ai l'impression vous
reculé devant les lobbyistes c'est grave
ce qui revient régulièrement
qu'est ce que c'est les lobbyistes c'est
qui le lobbyiste de la passoire
thermique c'est moi j'ai fait une bêtise
au début de mon quinquennat le l'irak
elle j'ai pas recruter j'ai pas reculer
devant le lobby des classes moyennes
françaises qui n'avaient rien choisi et
qui ont eu à subir la contribution
climat comme on l'appelait alors qu'il
avait deux voitures qu'ils habitaient
loin de l'endroit où ils travailler et à
qui on avait expliqué qu'il fallait se
déplacer en voiture
c'est ça ce qu'on a fait de ce qui a
déclenché la crise des gilet jaune c'est
pas un lobby
ce sont des gens qui veulent changer qui
sont conscients du vélo de ville avec un
métier à temps des seigneurs nicolas
hulot votre ancien menuisier sais pas
mais ok des faits dit moi les ailes je
réponds hg franchement 0 secret je
réponds à tous quel lobby quoi je vous
parle pas du lobby je vous parle de la
vie des gens quand on parle de
glyphosate c'est pas un lobby
je vous parle je vous parle de nos
agriculteurs c'est pas un lobby nos
agriculteurs ce sont des femmes et des
hommes qui s'est pas simplement un
métier sont dans un engagement qui
vivent jour et nuit pour nous nourrir
pourrait lever pour produire c'est pas
un lobby mais on a le droit de les
respecter
on veut tous mieux manger mieux vivre
mais simplement pendant des décennies on
leur a demandé de produire à marche
forcée et le voisin continue avec ça
faut qu'on les aide à faire série sera
longue et des achats scolaires qui
étaient dénoncées même terminé je vais
revenir sur chacun de ces points mais là
quand on parle de rénovation thermique
c'est pas un lobby ch par des françaises
et des français c'est-à-dire des gens à
qui on dit de changer très rapidement
pour les accompagner dans leur vie
quotidienne
c'est pas des lobis a donc juste la
transition écologique elle est
essentielle pour nous tous pour nos
générations et on est les premiers à le
faire nous il ya une génération qui a
dit celle du président chirac
la maison brûle il ya eu les des
générations ensuite si on fait des
grands projets celle de mes deux
prédécesseurs le président sarkozy le
président hollande
ils ont pris des lois pour les
successeurs ils ont fait des stratégies
autre nom la première génération qui se
tapent l'application c'est ça la vérité
est donc comme on applique bas on est
sur toutes les tensions de la société
est là aussi
ne jouons pas contre eux quand on doit
jouer ensemble on réussira pas de
transition sur les pesticides les
fongicides tous les produits chimiques
si on n'est pas avec les agriculteurs
on réussira pas la transition sur la
mobilité ou le
jugement c'est-à-dire changer de
véhicule la rénovation thermique si on
n'a pas avec nous l'ensemble des
françaises et des français en
particulier les plus modestes la
question il faut aider dans ce
changement questions sur les lobbys le
lobby de la chasse notamment alors bis
du nuc là les i lors le lobby nucléaire
allez la chasse il était évoqué
justement par votre ans alors ça c'est
pas du climat je peux y venir après et
bien sûr et sur la biodiversité lobby
nucléaire
je me fiche du lobby du nucléaire le
nucléaire m'importe le nucléaire c'est
des emplois et c'est l'énergie et moi je
ne suis pas anti nucléaire je lui ai
toujours dit avec beaucoup de force
je pense que nous avons eu raison de
réduire la part du nucléaire ça a été le
choix qui a été fait donc par le
président hollande de réduire
progressivement la part du nucléaire
d'ailleurs on a décalé cet horizon en
début de quinquennat avec nicolas hulot
pour qu'il soit réaliste mais pourquoi
le nucléaire dans notre pays il fallait
le réduire parce qu'on avait 75% de
l'électricité qu'on produisait sur la
base de nucléaire on dit on veut à terme
le ramener à 50
mais aujourd'hui si on veut lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique on
doit lutter contre quoi les particules
de co2 qu'on aimait et d'autres gaz
comme le hfc aux autres qui sont encore
pires dont on parle trop peu
celui qui est dans les climatiseurs
autres nous ont produit une électricité
qui est parmi les des plus décarbonés au
monde grâce à le voir grâce au nucléaire
donc qu'est ce qu'on doit faire on doit
aller beaucoup plus fort sur le
renouvelable garder notre force sur
l'hydraulique ça sont ceux
l'hydroélectricité on se bat à l'europe
là dessus et d'ailleurs edf est un grand
acteur
on doit là dessus réussir à avancer pour
faire plus de renouvelable
on a lancé beaucoup de projets sur
l'éolien en mer en particulier mais on à
l'éolien et le solaire
mais on doit préserver la part de
nucléaire c'est pas cédé au lobby c'est
ce sont des bruits de choses qui vous
êtes des créateurs définition du père
général pas inquiété par an et donc
c'est une réalité
moi j'ai besoin du nucléaire si je ferme
le nucléaire demain qu'est ce que je
fais je vais vous le dire
le nucléaire est une énergie décarbonée
non intermittente
je ne peux pas le remplacer du jour au
lendemain par des renouvelables
ceux qui disent ça c'est faux le
renouvelable il est intermittent par
définition est donc l'allemagne par
exemple qu'il ya encore plus de
renouvelable que nous quand elle a fermé
son nucléaire avec sa stratégie énergie
vers 2 elle a fait quoi elle a rouvert
des centrales à charbon de la limite et
elle a beaucoup
plus pollués c'est une réalité et tous
les pays qui ont fait ça beaucoup plus
polluée où ils ont accru leur exposition
à d'autres énergies fossiles comme le
gaz nous on a cette chance et donc le
nucléaire c'est ce qui nous permettra de
tenir d'abord on en attend ça peut faire
partie ça doit faire sans doute partie
de notre mix électrique
nous on doit continuer à développer le
renouvelable et on doit travailler sur
les techniques de stockage du
renouvelable pour qu'ils soient plus
intermittent la batterie et d'autres
steak d'autres techniques pour éviter
d'avoir des manques mais on a cette
chance ne la sacrifierons pas on est
parfois des champions pour donc c'est
pas du tout un lobby moi j'assume à fond
je crois dans le dans l'écologie je suis
pour qu'on soit parmi les champions de
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
si on veut réussir on doit réussir à
être meilleur encore sur le nucléaire et
ça veut dire aussi re continuer à
innover pour fermer le cycle continue à
être encore plus dans la sûreté et à
avoir un nucléaire encore plus sûr dans
nos pays dans tous les pays qui vont
d'ailleurs prendre le nucléaire dans
leur transition
les chasseurs c'est sûr c'est pas un
lobby j'espère c'est pas un lobby
bah non c'est parce que vous avez un
lobby mais c'est un groupe de pression
cacher les chasseurs ce sont des
millions de nos concitoyens qui
pratiquent cette activité dans la
ruralité c'est une réalité
quand je vois le président des chasseurs
c'est pas plus un lobby bar que je
connais du lot a démissionné en raison
en raison je pense qu'il a démissionné
pour beaucoup d'autres raisons lui
appartient j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour
nicolas hulot
il a dit ça je ne partage pas se taire
il a dit ça au sujet du lobby de la
chasse non il a parlé d'un lobbyiste
c'est sa profession qui l'accompagné
c'est tout à fait vrai mais quand je
pars le président des chasseurs
moi j'appelle passer un lobby c'est le
président d'une fédération ou alors dans
ces cas là vous appeler tout le toutou
lobby dans ces cas là tous les syndicats
sont des lobbys sont des groupes de
pression qui défendent des intérêts dans
ces cas là tous les représentants
patronaux sont des lobbys dans ces
cas-là tout l'effort secteur sont des
lobbys vos syndicats sont des lobbys bon
tout est tout et lobby dans ces cas-là à
partir du moment où on défend des
intérêts catégoriels et qu'on fait
pression sur la décision publique
ok si on dit c'est ça des lobbys je veux
bien y en a partout dans la société
la démocratie est fait de lobby
simplement souvent on utilise lobby pour
dire c'est des groupes de pression
cacher s'est pas cachée du tout moi j'ai
vu le président sereine qui est le
président la fédération des chasseurs
il ya 5 millions de chasseurs que ce
jeudi 5 mai on a même plus dans la
pratique et plusieurs millions de
chasseurs dans notre pays je pense que
c'est une activité qu'il faut encadrer
ce qu'on a fait à laquelle il faut
reconnaître sa place y compris dans la
préservation de la biodiversité et la
structuration de notre réalité et donc
j'assume totalement les mesures qui ont
été prises qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on a
fait on a on les a un on a fait une
réforme du permis qui a rendu plus juste
le système
c'était très attendue par certains
chasseurs parce qu'il avait un système
de permis très injuste ou en fait celle
qu'avait ceux qui avaient le plus
d'argent pouvait chasser entre
départements ça intéressera que les
chasseurs qui sont dans la communauté de
brutes et tous ceux qui nous suivent
on a à côté de ça en même temps dit aux
chasseurs vous devez être
responsabilisés et on a enfin réussi à
créer l'office français de la
biodiversité qui est donc un office
unique
on a rassemblé les équipes du ministère
de l'écologie toutes celles et ceux qui
préserver la biodiversité et celles et
ceux qui représentaient les chasseurs
des univers qui ne se parlaient pas et
on a réussi à mettre en place un système
où chaque année y ait un dialogue entre
experts entre toutes ses sensibilités
pour parler des espèces et de la chasse
et donc permettre de préserver notre
biodiversité pour avoir ce qu'on appelle
pardon du jargon mais une gestion
adaptative des espèces et je pense que
c'est intelligent de faire ça et c'est
intelligent de reconnaître que les
chasseurs on veut lutter contre les
pratiques qui ne sont pas conformes au
bien être animal
ensemble on veut réduire les pratiques
qui objectivement choc
ils ne sont pas conformes au monde dans
lequel on vit et en même temps on veut
aussi reconnaître que les chasseurs sont
des acteurs de la biodiversité de la
ruralité ce qui est une réalité ce que
le conseil d'état c'est un lobby par
exemple pour vous le conseil d'état
c'est une commune sollicite une aide
juridictionnelle conseil d'état et vous
donne trois mois pour justifier de votre
action écologique
c'est comme quelqu'un comme ça rien à
voir avec un lobby oui c'est normal
c'est un copain c'est une certaine forme
d'ultimatum qui vous est maintenant
presque ont appris dès le conseil d'état
et quand lee fait il fait son travail tu
avoues desire il n'est pas
contradictoire de dire on a fait
énormément de choses et d'avoir le
conseil d'état qui dit voilà la raison
c'est l'état français vous vous
représentez l'état parce que nous avons
nos pays pris des engagements comme tous
les pays très ambitieux
et nous nous sommes donnés des
contraintes et la pratique non mais
attendez c'est toujours pareil vous
mettez l'objectif là j'étais présent
vous avez pas bougé vous faites cette
route là je veux bien que vous vouliez
dire simplement vous êtes des nuls parce
que vous n'avez pas réussi à faire ces
derniers mètres et moi je suis premier à
dire je suis obsédée du résultat je me
battrai jusqu'au bout
donc je vais me battre pour faire ça
mais j'ai le droit de rappeler tout ce
qui a été faible sa déjà très dur et
devinez quoi
ça n'avait pas été fait avant c'est à
vous maintenant de l'urgence aujourd'hui
mais quand on nous dit moi je veux qu'on
sorte de cette espèce de 2,2 de débat
complètement fou qui consiste à dire on
est jeudi on n'est plus au temps des
invectives et de dire c'est l'urgence et
d'urgence et le jean ou le secteur nommé
concept mais non mais on doit continuer
à avancer
mais je veux dire ne disons pas non plus
en mais nous on n'a rien fait on doit
continuer à avancer
donc là je sors de la chasse vous
m'aviez entraîné j'ai expliqué une
position que j'assume totalement
pour aller vers le conseil d'état et nos
obligations donc que nous avons et qui
sont vérifiées par juridiction
administrative qui regarde si
l'administration est conforme aux lois
qu'elle sait que nous lui avons donné
est pareil l'europe regarde aussi les
engagements que nous avons pris et nous
ne sommes pas aujourd'hui à nos
engagements et donc on doit continuer
d'accélérer on à rattraper un certain
retard
là ces dernières années ça c'est une
réalité comment on peut continuer à
accélérer par rapport à ce que vous me
dites sur le conseil d'état ça c'est sûr
la la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et les émissions de co2 1
on doit accélérer sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
keane vraie source de pollution et donc
ça c'est ma prime rénove
je vous invite tous ceux qui qu'ils
veulent à aller sur sur le site
on a mis beaucoup d'argent dans la vie
dans le plan de relance c'est qu'il faut
qu'on convertissent d'airé des logements
qui sont qui font du gaspillage
énergétique en logements je dirais
beaucoup plus compatible avec notre at2
donc ça on a mis en place ce dispositif
faut maintenant qu'on accompagne nos
concitoyens pour qu'ils fassent ce
changement plus vite 2
on l'a fait avec la chaudière la
chaudière à un euro ça marche maintenant
très bien c'est pareil c'est permettent
de chauffer sa maison avait quelque
chose qui est beaucoup moins polluant et
elle est de plus en plus vers des
solutions qui sont les plus éco
compatibles troisième chose c'est
pousser les entreprises à le faire sans
le fait grâce à quoi un prix européen du
carbone
on pénalise de plus en plus les
entreprises qui polluent et on incite
les entreprises à moins polluer
4 c'est ce qu'on appelle se déplacer là
on a mis en place des forfaits mobilité
ou dans l'entreprise
on accompagne les gens qui font du
covoiturage et du vélo nature on a eu on
a mis beaucoup d'argent n'a mis un plan
vélo qu'on a boosté pour que les gens
utilisent davantage
on développe ce qu'on appelle
l'intermodalité la multimodalité c'est à
dire on pousse les gens à pas prendre la
voiture pour tous mais à utiliser le
vélo le transport en commun beaucoup
plus et à faire les connexions entre ces
transports en commun et la l'innovation
permet de répondre à ça et le grand défi
qui est nôtre c'est de convertir le parc
automobile anciens les vieux diesels et
les vieilles et des vieux véhicules
essence vers du nouveau et ça en plus
c'est intelligent par rapport à notre
tissu industriel et donc ça on l'a fait
en sortie de confinement en mettant
beaucoup de prime à la conversion on va
continuer de le faire et de l'accélérer
et j'ai demandé au gouvernement de
réfléchir sur des dispositifs très
innovant pour faire sa vie dernier point
g réunir est d'ailleurs lundi les
quelques grandes agglomérations
françaises qui sont là dessus c'est les
solutions locales s'est créé des zones à
faibles émissions dans les métropoles où
on sait on concentre les problématiques
les grandes métropoles françaises on
doit les aider à trouver des solutions
qui sont des régulations de transport
qui est de favoriser le transport en
commun qui est de permettre de réduire
par tous les émissions donc on est sûr
franchement on a lancé beaucoup de
choses maintenant qu'est ce qu'on doit
réussir à faire accélérer la mise en
oeuvre
y'a pas de chantier à défricher on doit
accélérer la mise en oeuvre en mettant
continuant à mettre beaucoup
d'investissement pour accompagner parce
que la transition écologique elle doit
être social on doit accompagner les plus
modestes dans cette transition et elle
est beaucoup plus fort sur les quelques
quelques points que je viens d'évoquer
alors monsieur présent il ya énormément
de questions les commentaires et on
salue toute la communauté de brutes qui
nous regardent actuellement je disais
des dizaines de milliers je pense qu'on
va approcher des 100000 sûrement avant
la fin de ce direct pour vous dire à
quel point il y en a énormément et il ya
une question plusieurs questions qui
sont même très importantes sur la
question de la place des femmes dans la
société française énormément de messages
animal et ce n'est d'ailleurs y en a une
qui revient très souvent c'est pourquoi
c'est une question de yant sur twitter
pourquoi les violences faites aux femmes
continuent d'augmenter
alors on va d'abord chaque violences
faites aux femmes est une violence de
trop et on a on est en train de vivre là
aussi une formidable transformation de
notre société il ya quelques années on
en parlait même pas où on allait
enregistrer même pas là on les
enregistre beaucoup plus de mieux en
mieux
on verra les chiffres que nous avons à
la fin de cette année et on a vraiment
train d'y répondre beaucoup plus
fortement
ça rejoint ce qu'on se disait au début
de la discussion il ya de la violence
dans la société
quand il ya de la violence dans la
société la preuve la première personne
qui la subissent et dans le foyer
il ya deux types de violences qui sont
intolérables c'est la violence faite aux
enfants qui est aussi là dont on parle
trop peu et dont je veux vraiment faire
un sujet essentiel dans les prochains
mois en lançant une grande commission un
grand travail qui a été préparé par le
secrétaire d'état de rien taquet mais
pour là aussi qu'on le dise qu'on le
mesure on écoute et qu'on y réponde
c'est pour moi un sujet essentiel
violence faite entre enfants à l'école
avec l'ours helmand et violences dans la
maison et gala violences faites aux
femmes en particulier est d'abord là
aussi à la maison et donc elles
continuent d'être là et ce qu'elles
augmentent en pratique je veux pas
rentrer dans un débat statistiques on
verra les chiffres qui sont mesurées à
la fin de l'année il y en a de toutes
façons toujours encore trop est beaucoup
trop et donc on doit lutter contre la
violence de la société et la violence
tout particulièrement qui s'est
développée qui s'est construit aussi sur
des représentations sociales
anthropologie qui est la violence à
l'égard des femmes dans le dans le foyer
au sein et au sein du couple
donc face à sa gamme un mouvement de
révélations formidable contre toutes les
formes de violences faites aux femmes
on a vu dans toutes les sociétés nous
l'avait vu venir quand je faisais
campagne dont on avait fait cette grande
marche
c'était le premier sujet qui ressortait
déjà quand on interrogeait les gens de
manière anonyme dans la grande marche en
avait fait le premier sujet c'était les
violences le harcèlement drevet donc
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on a commencé à
faire qu'est ce qu'on doit faire face à
ça d'abord contre toutes les formes de
violence parce que ça commence dans les
détails c'est ne rien toléré on a on
sanctionne maintenant on a mis en place
un délit dans la rue quand vous êtes à
ceux des insultes et qu'il y ait un
début de violence même
je dirais langagière qui est là pour
sanctionner analyse il ya je crois près
de 2000 mais une sanction qui ont été
prononcées c'est un travail très
important
2 on doit réussir à faire que au sein du
foyer la parole se libère et que les
moyens de porter plainte de deux et
surtout d'abord de dire puis de porter
plainte se fasse moi j'étais ya quelques
jours dans un foyer extraordinaire la
part il ya quelques quelques rues d'ici
deux femmes qui ont été battus parfois
pendant des années il ya une autocensure
pourquoi on est plus en plus parce que
pendant longtemps on n'a pas dit et
parce que quand on est battu chez soi
quelque part il ya une forme de
normalisation qui se crée on se dit si
je suis battu
il ya peut-être une raison et sait sont
souvent des processus très pervers qui
se met en place
ou celui qui bat créé un système de
dépendance de domine de domination est
donc la première chose pour lutter
contre la violence faite aux femmes
c'est d'avoir un discours public qui
rentre dans les foyers de ménages kindy
il n'y a rien qui justifie quelques
violence est la violence ça commence à
la gifle il n'y a rien qui justifie
quelques violences physiques et même
psychique mental y'a rien qui justifie
d'être d'avoir une sorte de rêve de
domination et donc faut d'abord le dire
le dire aux amis aux voisins ouvrir la
parole pour qu'eux aussi le rapport à
l'autre permet de faire parfois de
prendre conscience donc il ya un premier
truc c'est lutter contre l'autocensure
libérer la parole la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il faut que cette parole
ensuite elles puissent être reçus et que
vous portiez plainte et donc qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a mis en place
évidemment on a simplifié la plainte
on a mis en place la possibilité par sms
de porter plainte
on a la plateforme 39,19 gérer insisté
on va la développer
7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 est un
ami et je remercie d'ailleurs le réseau
des pharmaciens on a mis en place la
possibilité pour les femmes parce que
souvent c'est la pharmacie qu'elles vont
tout seul pour acheter des choses qui
sont plus intime et que l'ale sont pas
accompagnés par le compagnon ou le mari
qui ira c'est dans cette emprise pour
qui et en pharmacie la possibilité de
dire chez le pharmacien chez le médecin
dans certains points de supermarchés et
on va on est en train aussi on a
commencé de simplifier la plainte pour
que les plantes puissent être prises
dans certains services de soins à
l'hôpital ont des cellules d'écouté pour
que la plainte
évidemment soit systématique
quand on va à la police la gendarmerie
et on a formé beaucoup de policiers et
de gendarmes à la compréhension à la
prise de plainte des violences faites
aux femmes
et puis on a mis en place aussi des
cellules au sein de la justice pour y
répondre beaucoup plus vite et puis
ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a créé
des places d'hébergement mais cette
année mais l'année prochaine et
bracelets pour les justes je fais ça
rapidement parce que c'est un énorme
travail qui a été fait là ses dernières
années à marche forcée et s'est pas
encore assez parce que je sais que les
associations elles veulent beaucoup plus
mais là aussi on a tous un rôle celui de
ne pas accepter des petits signaux qu'on
voit parfois au sein de la famille ou
chez le voisin
et ça commence là on a une autre
question à concrètes qui contient cette
fois la précarité menstruel vient de
clémence qui nous dit à quand la
gratuité des protections hygiéniques
comme voté en écosse oui je pense
c'était un sujet sur lequel j'ai demandé
qu'on avance et il sera dans les
prochains mois je veux qu'en tout cas
avec les associations qui sont
compétentes et et pour toutes les femmes
qui sont dans cette situation on puisse
avoir une réponse donc je veux pas
préempter le travail du gouvernement
mais c'est quelque chose qui au premier
semestre de l'année prochaine aura une
réponse très concrètes parce que quand
on voit en effet des femmes qui sont
dans la très grande précarité qui sont à
la rue elles vivent tout ce que vivent
un homme de d'épuisement physique de
réduction de votre durée de vie de deux
maladies qu'on contracte d'humiliation
et elle vit en plus de choses si on se
parle très franchement elle vit en effet
la précarité monstre est ce que vous
l'avez dit le fait d'avoir des règles
dans la rue et de pas pouvoir acheter de
quoi ce quoi se protéger de quoi
justement être digne dans la journée et
de vie de viol en plus des autres même
si malheureusement aussi et des jeunes
garçons qui vivent le viol dans la rue
et donc ça c'est une action sur lequel
je compte on renforce le travail avec
avec les associations de services
sociaux les communes et l'ensemble de
cette est ce qu'il ya une question
monsieur le président qui revient
énormément dans les commentaires on a
reçu des milliers message concernant la
situation des ouigours cette minorité
musulmane qui compte environ 11 millions
de personnes dans l'ouest l'extrême
ouest de la chine
aujourd'hui beaucoup pointent une
certaine forme d'inaction de votre part
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez
aujourd'hui je trouve c'est d'abord je
trouve que c'est assez injuste parce que
je les dis je me suis engagé je les dis
publiquement
surtout je les dis à mes homologues
chinois ce qui moi je ne suis pas un
militant à chaque fois qu'on parle des
différents sujets c'est ce qu'il faut
comprendre
vous pouvez dire parfois il n'a pas le
même langage que moi ou il n'est pas
assez mais de là où je suis quelle est
l'action utile que doit mener je ne vais
pas déclencher la guerre à la chine sur
ce sujet mais c'est non mais c'est
d'avoir est-ce que ça à la hauteur de
l'urgence de la situation aujourd'hui
alors je vous annonce millions de
personnes on a tous vu à l'espace en
raison je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire ce qui à mes yeux est à la hauteur
d'abord ma responsabilité c'est d'en
parler mais à faire au président chez
jean ping aux autorités chinoises quand
elles viennent en france où quand je
fais en chine et c'est de le dire
publiquement ce que j'ai fait ensuite
c'est d'avoir une stratégie européenne
parce que là aussi si on veut être fort
face à la chine fois très clair il faut
avoir un peu de réalisme géopolitique
c'est l'europe en oeuvre c'est l'europe
nous européens on doit défendre nos
valeurs aujourd'hui ce qui est menacé
c'est une forme de relativisme mon
niveau valeurs occidentales se sont pas
déjà les droits de l'homme la dignité de
la personne humaine la lutte contre le
travail forcé se sont pas des valeurs
qui sont européennes ce sont des valeurs
universelles
l'europe doit défendre ses valeurs
universelles donc moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que nous européens dans notre
dialogue avec la chine on porte cet exil
cette exigence et qu'on demande quoi la
cessation immédiate de ces camps la
cessation immédiate des violences qui
sont ça passe par des sanctions
justement ça c'est justement ça on doit
le faire on a faveur de l'échalote c'est
aussi mais bien sûr c'est que la fille
gina timmings beaucoup plus qui fait
qu'il ya parfois beaucoup plus de
prudence
mais de là où je suis moi je dois aller
chercher à voir une action efficace je
respecte les chinoises des chinois je
respecte les autorités comme avec tout
pays et j'ai toujours eu ce rapport
d'ailleurs qui est un rapport de vérité
pas d'invectivés d'exigence et d'essayer
de trouver le chemin utile dans le
rapport diplomatique
c'est entre l'europe et la chine qu'on
va trouver la solution ça doit d'abord
passer par l'exigence d'envoyer une
mission des nations unies et des autres
doivent des observateurs internationaux
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on
ne peut pas accepter d'un membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité c'est
de refuser toute présence et toute
capacité des nations unies et des ong à
voir
et à apporter une réponse qui est manu
terre et de trouver une solution
et ensuite il doit y avoir un dialogue
entre l'union européenne et la chine sur
ce sujet je pense que c'est notre devoir
et je pense que nous européens ont fait
de la géopolitique de la souveraineté du
commerce
mais on fait aussi une géopolitique qui
doit être respectueuse de nos valeurs
comme ce qu'on a fait sur la liberté
d'expression donc oui donc moi je les
dis j'ai commencé à le faire a lancé je
veux qu'on accélère je veux qu'on le
fasse en européen c'est comme ça que
j'ai proposé qu'on structure la relation
avec la chine comme président chen ping
est venue à paris au printemps 2010 8 en
a parlé mais j'ai fait venir à l'époque
le président juncker et la chancelière
merkel c'est comme ça qu'on doit
structurer le dialogue avec la chine et
après je pense qu'on a tous un rôle à
jouer aussi dire les quant à une
entreprise un pays qui ce comportement
les politiques de de mobilisation
citoyenne elles sont très importantes
pour mettre la pression et vous le
faites il ya une question qui est
revenue quand même par rapport aux coûts
sont en lice il fixe trois cent mille
trois cent mille c'est le double qu'en
valoriser la délégation ad c'est vrai
mais là dessus d'ailleurs la ministre
l'a très bien dit soyons tous
collectivement honnête on parle des gens
aussi qui sont prises dans les
structures d'urgence qu'on a créés on ne
dit pas il ya trois cent mille personnes
qui vivent dans la rue chaque soir il
faut continuer à faire des opérations
vérité pour voir qui est dans la rue de
chaque soir on peut pas satisfaire de ça
mais évidemment mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que notre réponse est aussi
face à ce problème
une réponse qui n'est pas l'inaction qui
a été un investissement dans
l'hébergement d'urgence dans des centres
dans des réponses sociales
d'accompagnement avec ses 2 milliards
d'euros qu'on investit cette année pour
répondre justement à ce défi mais qu'est
ce qui explique sa de la précarité qu'on
a dans une partie de dans une partie de
notre jeunesse de la grande fragilité
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer
à y répondre avec la stratégie qu'on a
lancé de permettre réinsertion dans la
société de l'accompagnement humain parce
qu'on lutte pas justement simplement par
des dispositifs financiers avec ça ça
arrive dans un des pays qui aide le plus
au monde les personnes en précarité
on est un des pays qui a le salaire
minimum le plus universel est parmi les
plus élevées et nous sommes un pays on a
des filets de sécurité parmi les plus
nombreux donc comment
situation se construit c'est c'est par
une faille qu'on allait manque
d'accompagnement sociaux à certains
endroits et l'autre sujet qu'on a c'est
la précarité qui est liée à
l'immigration illégale et qui est lié à
cette ce détournement de la procédure du
droit d'asile où on a aujourd'hui
plusieurs milliers dizaines de milliers
plusieurs dizaines de milliers par an
une chute l'année dernière c'était même
plus cent mille femmes et hommes qui
arrivent des routes de la misère dont
certaines et certains auront un titre et
ont droit à l'asile et dont beaucoup
n'auront pas l'asile soit parce qu'ils
sont dans un processus du but de dublin
et ils ont déjà demandé dans des pays
voisins soit parce qu'ils viennent de
pays dans lesquels on donne chaque année
des dizaines ou des centaines de
milliers de visas qui sont pas des pays
du tout en guerre qui sont pas des pays
où ils sont menacés
et donc là aussi il faut qu'on ait une
réponse mais qui se construit avec les
pays d'origine et les pays de transit
qui se construit dans le dialogue pour
éviter ça c'est ça la réalité de cette
situation mais sur ces trois cent mille
je vais être très clair la ministre
wingles a rappelé on a beaucoup de
femmes et d'hommes qui sont pris dans
notre dispositif d'urgence mais comme
vous l'avez dit on peut pas s'en
satisfaire maintenant près de deux
heures que l'on parle avec cette
jeunesse le dresseur même plus de deux
heures fera que ça fait à peu près deux
heures et demie mais il ya eu tellement
de questions dans les commentaires on
aura pu encore en prendre des milliers
d'autres auxquelles vous aurez
l'occasion pouvoir répondre sur ce match
at on retrouvera ça demain ça fait deux
heures que l'on parlait que cette
jeunesse monsieur le président parmi ces
jeunes qui ont voté en 2017
chez les 18 24 ans ils ont voté en un
pour jean luc mélenchon en deux pour
marine le pen vous n'étiez finalement à
l'époque que troisième est-ce que lors
de votre campagne de réélection en 2022
la jeunesse sera votre priorité
j'ai jamais considérer la jeunesse ni
comme une catégorie ni comme une cible
électorale
moi je me souviens d'avoir été jeune je
n'avait de cesse de vieillir c'est vrai
jeu
j'aimais pas qu'on me parle comme si
c'était un statut je pense qu'il ya
plein de jeunesse différente et je pense
que vous leur parlerez durant cette
campagne je sais comme comme je vous ai
parlé là c'est à dire avec mes
convictions je pense que là je pense que
les la jeunesse française les jeunesse
française
elles sont plus exigeantes que les
autres en termes d' authenticité donc je
pense qu'il faut savoir dire quand on se
trompe sur quelque chose quand on n'est
pas d'accord je pense qu'il faut pas
servir un discours qui est celui qui
correspond
une catégorie tout est transparent tous
se croisent donc ils sont pas idiots ils
sont ils sont nés avec le numérique est
surinformés donc si vous dites un truc
qui plaît à un jeune en disant toi le
jeune je vais dire ce que fais tu
attends parce que je compte être réélu
je peux vous dire que ça finit rarement
bien jeu parce que l'information est
universel donc donc je n'ai jamais
considéré c'était une chose que je veux
pour moi ce qui est important c'est que
d'abord on arrive à ce que cette
génération qui est une génération au
fond de moi je dirais de l'exigence de
l'inquiétude légitime parce que c'est
une génération qui vit là le coc vide on
en a parlé qui vit la précarité le doute
qui a eu à vivre quand on est jeune en
âge on est tous très différents ça
dépend de l'endroit ont vu du milieu du
moment mais on a toujours quand même des
dégâts des grands doutes existentiels
qui correspondent évidemment à ce moment
de la vie qui est celui où on pas on
quitte la famille et on se projette vers
l'âge adulte et donc on a cette
inquiétude sur l'emploi il y en a sept
inquiétudes sur la vie sentimentale
moi je suis frappé par une chose la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui est là elle a en
plus l'inquiétude sa vulnérabilité
toutes les grandes questions qui sont
hérités des générations d'avant le
climat et ses audits ce terrorisme et
est là dessus ni justes et elle a en
plus cette inquiétude renouveler à cause
de cette vulnérabilité
comment on transforme cette inquiétude
ce besoin de sens en engagement pour ça
je suis venu chez vous parce que ce que
j'aime bien c'est l'idée de dire on ne
fait pas de concessions mais on prend
possession de la concession vous parler
de l'avenir
je parlerai aux jeunes comme je parlerai
ce soir oui c'est à dire vous sept
candidats pour 2022
n'essayez pas de me faire dire ce que je
n'ai pas dit on vous l'avait plus vous
l'avez plus ou moins vous allez vous
avez plus ou moins vous avez décidé je
parlerai aux jeunes non mais alors
vraiment enlacés je parlerai aux jeunes
comme je parlerai ce soit vraiment une
grande car version b qualifie c'est une
citation c'est ce que vous avez dit on
pouvait mais non mais je dis je
continuerai je me suis placé dans une
situation gênante éthiques
mais non je vais être là dessus très
très franchement on part en sincérité
mais je parle en sincérité je suis en
plein dedans
on est dans un pays où la campagne
présidentielle elle commence quand je
vois là tout le monde ce qu'ils sont en
train de dire appelé à me soutenir pour
être candidat aux certains commencent
leur campagne
un an et demi ou deux ans avoue le
commencerez camp mais si vous dites vous
faites deux autres campagnes pour armand
dac
du repas pas cinq ans on arrive à pas à
faire deux choses utiles
donc non ce qui est important moi je
suis toujours de toute façon je serai
jusqu'au dernier jour dans l'action et
la conviction
donc j'ai envie de dire je suis en
permanence en train d'essayer de me
battre de convaincre et d'avancé j'ai
jamais arrêté je me suis jamais installé
dans un siège en disant ça va être
formidable maintenant je vais pouvoir
profiter parce que d'abord les
circonstances ne l'ont pas permis c'est
pas mon tempérament
et donc ce travail de conviction dont je
vous parle pour la jeunesse j'avais dire
je suis candidat depuis premier jour
c'est que vous voulez entendre parce que
je me suis toujours construit bâti dans
une volonté de de convaincre et n est
d'être au rendez vous des résultats mais
je n'ai pas le droit aujourd'hui de vous
dire et de me mettre dans une
disposition d'esprit d'être candidat
pourquoi pas ce que ça veut dire que je
rentrerai dans un une disposition
d'esprit et d'action où je ne prends
plus les risques que je dois prendre et
où je ne réponds plus à l'exigence du
moment on vit quand même des temps qui
sont assez inédit on le sait si demain
je ne prends pas les décisions parfois
dures parfois impopulaires
via ce n'est pas populaire des choses
que je fais en ce moment si je me mets
dans la situation d'être un candidat je
ne prends je ne prendrai plus les bonnes
décisions
je le sais et donc ça viendra si ça doit
venir au moment voulu je n'ai pas la
réponse ce soir là dessus parce que je
pense que je pensais pas une bonne idée
ni pour la nation ni pour moi même et
que ce serait pour le coup un sincère et
peut-être que je vais peut-être que je
pourrai pas être candidat peut-être que
je devrais faire des choses dans la
dernière année dans les derniers mois
dur parce que les circonstances
l'exigeront et qui rendront impossible
le fait que je sois candidat je n'exclus
rien on a vécu des choses qui étaient
absolument imprévisible donc je ne
prévois rien donc voilà je veux
simplement vous dire ça mais moi ya un
point qui me tient à coeur
par rapport à tout ce qu'on s'est dit si
notre peau de conclusion c'est que c'est
que cette génération engagée soit une
génération dû faire de l'action et moi
j'ai eu parfois quand on est là où je
suis c'est normal on a une fonction
institutionnelle on prend des décisions
fait des choix avec la part
d'impopularité d'insatisfaction je vous
comprenez aussi que de là où je suis en
quelque sorte
je veux être un allié sur les sujets qui
sont les vôtres
un allié pour lutter contre les
inégalités les injustices pour essayer
d'aller plus fort
climat et pour que chacune et chacun on
arrive à bâtir ce que c'est qu'être
français c'est notre plus grand défi
toutes les batailles là qu'on a parlé
des grands débats on y arrivera si on
arrive à ré inventer collectivement ce
que c'est qu'être français c'est à dire
ce récit collectif où chacun a son sa
part d'histoire à raconter être à
traduire l'un l'autre et donc à
s'écouter et je veux être un allié pour
ça merci monsieur le président d'avoir
répondu à mes questions si celle de yamo
attendent inquiets qui m'accompagnait
pour soleil mais aussi merci à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivis par un peu plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de commentaires
vous avez été très nombreux à poser des
questions et on a essayé en tout cas de
faire notre maximum pour en remonter
auprès du président de la république
beaucoup de tendances beaucoup de
commentaires et vous pourrez alors voir
tout ça en replay dans quelques instants
comme d'habitude vous en avez l'habitude
nos directs sont à retrouver en
intégralité dans quelques instants ce
sera le cas et ce sera le cas aussi de
pouvoir nous retrouver demain puisque
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
contre l'article 24 de la loi sécurité
globale s'élancera dans les rues paris
on la suivra bien évidemment comme
slogan ne soyez pas violents
traquer toutes celles et ceux qui seront
violents dont fera juste de travail de
journaliste est vraiment aucun souci
véritable bien sûr et je pense que là
dans la période on a surtout besoin de
se mobiliser pour construire évidemment
et donc on suivra ça demain à paris
faire en direct sur brut très bonne
soirée à vous et à très bientôt